what's the one on the bottom right I
don't recogniz that's that's a
YouTuber also I thought that was just
fan art of
you kind of look like you me I am my
favorite thing of this
year hello everyone welcome back to
another festive episode of the trash
taste podcast I'm Joey and I'm with my
festive co-host Conor and G that's not a
very festive opening happy holidays
everyone by the time this comes out it's
right before Christmas I believe right
before
Christmas hope you guys have done your
Christmas shopping there's no last
minute Christmas shopping I'm sure
definitely got still got to do that what
do you guys want for Christmas by the
way your company no no what do you want
I don't [__] know I can't give you
that what do you want your your presence
is a your friendship I got I got we're
still we're still friends for like
another year right guys I just want to
cherish now that's why they call it the
the present
oh but anyway uh we're going what do you
want they call it they call it the
present because it is a present Joey
that's that's that's what the saying is
surely whatever it was a [__] bad is it
bad to ask someone what they want or is
it better to no no the problem is I
can't answer that question because I
genuinely don't know yeah me neither
this is the problem I have with every
Christmas time everybody around me asks
what do you want and I say I don't know
I wish I knew we have something you did
did yeah yeah you told me you wanted I
was like what wait what I told you
something oh know remember Sydney told
me what you wanted and I was like are
you sure he wants it oh okay Sydney
being wait wait what do you want what do
you want what do you want uh I just like
off the top of my head I've been getting
into like fidget toys
recently I actually Sydney said H there
is not what Syd not what Sydney said do
you want a fidget spinner like what do
you want no not a fidget spinner Joey
okay is that not a fidget toy that's
that's a fidget toy made for someone who
doesn't fidget all right like swear down
I've seen like I've been getting
recommended a lot of different fidget
toy videos and some of them I'm just
like oh that looks really really good
actually do you know one of the best
fidget toys I've had recently what it
was a present that you gave actually
what it was the belt buckle and and so
Conor like I asked for a belt right and
Conor gave me a belt buckle and it just
has this really satisfying click right
when when you like flip it it has such a
strong satisfying click wait was this
what brand is it uh I think it was
Calvin CL it has such a satisfying click
when you rotate it and I'm not actually
used it
as swear down swear down I have not yet
used he's just sitting there in his
office just clicking away at this ble
swear this is like when parents buy
their kids like a ton of like or like
when they buy pets they buy like a cat
or a dog a bunch of amazing toys and
they playing with with the spring on the
door yeah yeah literally swe I haven't
actually used it as a bell yet cuz it's
just been sitting on my desk and I just
like I just twiddle with it because I'm
just like so do I have another do I have
to buy another belt that you actually
use I I don't know ever last year you
like I need a belt to use and now I find
out you're using the [__] thing or
just buy him another Calvin Klein but
only the belt buckle part yeah I should
yeah I should rip off I've been I've
been getting curious about like
different fidget toys cuz I I bought one
in uh Korea and it was it'll [__] I I
I've kind of realized the difference
between good fidget
toys there needs to be something like
satisfying well now I'm scared to buy
you any like fidget toy for Christmas
because there's a chance that I'll give
it to you and you'll be like this is
[__] I I want to your standards for
Fusion you want to know the funny origin
of where your belt came from where I
probably should say this so I I I I went
to this donkey hot and I remember you
told me you wanted this MH uh and I got
sidetracked I wasn't actually looking
for a birthday present
Christmas it was Christmas last
Christmas and I went to uh this really
cool donkey hot that was like eight
floors or something in Hokkaido and
there was a a $100 gacha machine and I
was like [__] yeah I was like [__] okay
and in my head I was like this is before
if if if YouTube shorts are on my mind
at the time I would have I would have
made a short about it or something but I
was like well [__] I got I'm want to
find out so I just unloaded like 500
bucks into this thing to see what I got
my God and I realized I was like wait
hold on a second uh wait was it 5 I
think it was 100 bucks like $60 a go uh
and the worst thing you could get you
basically got like a a a level so it's e
to A to B whatever and uh I got four e
which was the worst and one like C okay
uh and the E you could choose from this
cabinet a bunch of stuff uh and and I
was looking at the prices of some of
these things on Amazon and a lot of them
were more than ichiman oh and I was like
wait a second this is is like this is
great yeah and so I got I got one of the
belts from that oh [__] cuz that belt
was going for like 80 bucks was that the
e r that was one of the worst rank ones
yeah uh cuz I I got a GTA prize I'll
take it yeah but it was like it was it
was I I was looking on Amazon it was
more money to buy it on Amazon than it
was to play this GAA and lose and then
get it and I was like huh see but that's
cool but now that we've known the true
nature of what happened to this belt you
basically paid 80 bucks for a [__]
fidget toy hey I've SE
$60 okay I've seen some of the price of
these fidget toys and some of them go
from like 10 bucks that's that's all the
like the [__] ones they can go for like
hundreds of bucks some of these fidget
toys because they like so intricately
made so Japanese engineering like
[__] insane [__] but we're not
talking about fidget toys we're not
talking about belts we're talking about
our favorite things of 2023 we've
decided to make a little 3x3 to kind of
reflect on the year of 20 23 and
basically share I guess the nine things
that we were really invested in or we
really want to talk about that we
discovered in23 yeah oh god oh sorry
okay who who go me one of you preface
not everything has to be from 2023 just
things that we discovered or things that
we enjoyed in 2020 yeah because we've
had two three Christmas episodes before
so we thought we'd do something
different and just reflect on we we're
going to be self-indulgent and just be
like hey this is what we liked in 2023
have to be any theme doesn't doesn't
have to be any particular thing can be
literally anything that we wanted to
talk about that we discovered in 2023
and if you want trash taste odds are I
imagine some of these might have come up
on trash taste I've tried to pick stuff
that I haven't talked about so much on
trash taste before or things that fair
enough I've got a mix half I've
definitely spoken about a lot yeah I'm
about a mix as well I think yeah so who
wants to go first why don't you you're
the host off you can go first okay bring
on my 3x3 that I defitely just scrambled
together no what the heck is
this okay okay okay you know you know
what's really funny I was thinking back
on like all right what are the like some
of the newer things that I got into in
2023 and I sat there and thought about
and I was like damn am I getting old or
do I just not remember what happened
this year uh yes either that or you've
uh gone back to your [__] childhood
yeah I was going to say like if you
remove the crown this could be a kids
list yeah
literally remove the crown what age uh
what age range are we
talking literally I think I might have G
back sometimes going back to the roots
is where it's at yeah man okay I got to
ask yeah Crown ain't no way come on okay
legitimately legitimately I started
watching the crown I didn't really start
watching it this year it was more like
late last year that I like kind of
discovered and uh you know at first when
I looked at the concept of this show I
was just like oh it's about like the
British Monarchy I didn't really care
about the I mean every Australian
doesn't really care about the British
Monarchy all that kind of stuff but I
thought [__] it whatever I'll give it a
go I'll give it a watch and I really
[__] enjoyed it like it's a really
good show I would like to give my
thoughts on the show to see if you kind
of feel similarly okay uh first like two
to three seasons bang a television bang
a television some of the best out there
because I feel like the crown pre like
televised history was really really
interesting yeah absolutely and then
afterwards especially when the crown of
season 4 and light season were really
[__] bad uh I thought the latest
season of the crowd the crown the one
with like Diana well all the Diana
seasons have been some of the most
boring TV I've ever seen in my life I
think it's definitely gone down since
yeah when like Diana came into the
picture like definitely that far in the
ground yet okay yeah cuz like right now
it's like season six I think which is
the last season three seasons of this
show di yeah what I mean like look I get
it like now that I have like fully sat
through the entire series and I've
actually learned a lot like it's
actually kind of an achievement this
show made me kind of interested in
learning about the history of like the
British Monarchy which I didn't give a
[__] about before but like yeah as kind
of said like first three seasons of like
when you know uh Elizabeth was still
like very very young and just got you
know just became queen stuff like that
that [__] was super interesting cuz i'
never learned anything about that and
again it was just like really well-made
television that actually made me give
[__] about something I previously didn't
give a [__] I had to I had to constantly
catch myself in the first few seasons
being nearly caring about the family I
no no Welsh ancestors I'm not forgetting
he nearly got me I nearly sympathize
season one I was still like in denial of
was like I mean yeah this is cool but
like I don't quite care yet and then
season 2 hereit I'm like all right I'm
invested you know when you like start
watching that like trash TV show that
you significant other is watching and
then you start off being like what is
this [__] but then you stick around for
a while and then couple days later
you're like fully invested in it like
wait honey can we uh watch can we watch
the next episode please what what do you
mean you watched their head what the
[__] so the CR I'd say like out of all
of the Netflix shows kind of live action
shows I'd say that one probably stuck
out to me the most because again it made
me care about something I previously
would have never thought I'd get into
yeah I think if they had just wrapped up
the Diana stuff in like a season as
opposed to three we would have been how
many seasons of the crown is there now
six currently six and half of it is
Diana [__] yeah like like four yeah four
and five is like very heavily focused on
di I got through divorce the beginning
of season 3 and then I stopped and then
I was like H probably the best thing to
do yeah it kind of goes downhill a
little bit I think the second half of
season six has just come out which I
haven't watched yet but apparently
that's going to be like the end of the
series cuz you know what what are they
going to do after that all right so Lego
yeah what's what's that up about what's
up with that Joe what's up with that
look as a kid I'm sure sure everyone had
that like you know Lego bucket Lego
collection as did I you know I loved
playing with Legos as a kid and then
when I got older I realized oh there are
Lego boxes for adults like like massive
Lego collections for adults all leg
Legos you know I think there's most
Legos are for every age and there are
some that are more catered towards kids
more cater towards kids and then there
are ones where it's just like like
there's a couple of boxes that I bought
which like straight up just say 18 plus
and I was just like oh okay what are you
building titties yeah that's what I
thought I'm like it's a bit of a weird
like way to advertise it but like yeah
um cuz like you know growing up I loved
like building Legos and like did you
guys ever have like these things called
meos yeah yeah like it's basically like
it's like Lego except they're metallic
pieces and you use like nuts and bolts
and screws to like put everything
together more gears and and like you can
add Electronics to it and stuff like
that it's basically like Hasbro is my
first robotic I watch that guy on
YouTube who builds Lego machines oh he
he's like how many gears can I add to
this system and then he just or he's
like I'm going to make an underwater car
of Lego and you're like okay that's
that's sick yeah just [__] like that so
it's like uh and Japan as well has like
a bunch of Lego stores all over and
there's one kind of near my house and
like I I would go into it every now and
then just to be like oh I wonder what
like how Lego has evolved and then I
went in and I saw like a bunch of like
really [__] sick Lego pieces that I
was just like you know what I'm going to
go back to my childhood and just like
build a bunch of Legos just to see what
it's like and it's been it's it's I've
kind of used it as my form of meditation
this year of just like just playing some
music or like putting on a show on TV
and just like sitting down and just
building a Lego do anything but watch
anime I mean to be fair I did watch I
watch Paradise while building
Legos okay so give me your what your top
three Lego sets top three Lego sets Okay
so the one I recently finished was um
you know the Giant Wave painting by
katus Hawai like Japanese pain yeah gave
this one away in my Charity Auction yeah
yeah yeah so it's that like the Lego set
of that and it's kind of like this like
really cool it creates this really cool
3D Lego painting and you can like
actually they built it so that you can
actually hang it up on the wall so we
have it hung up on our on our wall and
it actually looks kind of dope the
coolest one by far though is I built a
fully functioning Pac-Man arcade machine
out of Legos oh that's sick
yeah and I'll I'll I'll send a video to
Mud as well point in the episode but
basically you can build this it's it's
probably it stands about this tall um
and it's this fully operating I say
fully operating but like there's a lot
of moving parts to it but like instead
of accidentally playing on the arcade
like with the joystick or whatever
there's a crank on the side and it and
the actual screen you can actually move
around the Pac-Man and all of the yeah
this thing so I built this oh sick and
the top part uh has like the Pac-Man
logo which you can like press a button
and it flips around wait so is it like
an actual screen in a game uh no no so
all of this this is like built out of
Legos what can I see a video can we go
on a video I want to see how this works
and so basically it it's made to look
like a screen but what it is is that
it's these individual like Pac-Man Lego
pieces that are on a little chain I had
no idea that Lego went this they're
going ham bro have they already stopped
selling this cuz I already sold resale
prices for like 500 bucks uh I don't
know actually but yeah this is the exact
one I holy [__] and AI bought uh bought
this for me for my birthday and can you
skip ahead see where he's playing so
that little crank on the side there you
can crank it and all of the inside like
pieces like the Pacman's and the ghosts
they kind of move around on a chaines
what and you build all of that from
scratch this I think this took me about
two full days to make that's insane yeah
head to when he's playing with it yeah
yeah so you can like press buttons
lights turn on uh you can move the
joysticks around stuff like
that um yeah so like those individual
like pellets and stuff like that you
have to punch them all in and then by
spinning the thing it moves the pieces
around to make it look like it's
actually like moving and functioning so
it doesn't actually obviously it can't
like actually play a game but it can so
go to the most replay part there yeah so
it's like that wait that's actually sick
wait that's so sick yeah right it's
[__] cool wait can you but you can't
get the pallets right no no no so so you
have to attach them to the chains it
just and
there's but that way that's so sick
though the fact that it even like can
like emulate yeah right the only thing
that stresses me out about Lego and I'm
sure you might have been dealing with
this conundrum is uh where the [__] do I
put all this [__] when I'm done cuz like
you run out of room fast with Lego cuz
Lego's big yeah need to have like a room
dedicated to just Lego yeah I've just
I've just kind of put this is why every
guy needs a like a man closet you know
Jaan Japan does not allow the man cave I
know it doesn't Conor we don't we don't
live in rural Ohio G I have 15 spare
rooms okay that's why when you [__]
reach your 40s or whatever you go into
like the countryside and you get a
basement where you build just you like a
basement where you just build [__] and
it's just where it's it's the it's the
place where [__] just accumulates right
so all of my Lego stuff I put on the
same shelf as all my gun
plaws so it's just like I have a
dedicated I I have a dedicated shelf of
like this is the [__] I made uh so
that's I you know I love gum but I think
the one thing that Lego has just done
amazingly is not requiring tools like
you build so many things without tools
or if they you know if you do need tools
it's yeah my my biggest problem with
gunpla is you need a [__] [__]
like John Wick tool kit you got to wrap
out and necessarily need to all you
really need is a pair of necessarily I
but you know if you want to go like full
like you got to get like the paint out
you got to get the [__] fiddly fiddly
little stickers you got to get the
Sandpaper as well the Sandpaper as well
and that is just way too much
craftmanship for me but like the cool
thing is is that like uh you know with
the hawky painting I made uh because
that is like pretty just looks nice and
you can put it on the wall we've like
started dedicating a little area of our
house to like kind of turn into like a a
like an old Japanese style thing so
another one I built it's not a Lego
necessarily it's like Nano blocks which
is like a smaller version of Legos but I
built a bonsai out of that so so I just
placed the Bonsai next to the painting
and it just looks nice it like actually
matches the theme and there's another
one where it's like a full Japanese
garden which o really wants me to make
to like match that going to be the Lego
guy soon I already am like man but yeah
like it just made me realize like yeah I
[__] miss just like you know
mindlessly just like making some cool
[__] and like again it's been like a
great way to just kind of like turn off
from everything and just like meditate
almost uh so yeah if you're an adult
yeah go get some Legos it's uh it's it's
good fun um let's see what else do we
have I mean obviously top left uh tears
of the Kingdom I think we talked about
that on an episode did we I think I did
I don't know but did you enjoy it that
much I played the [__] out of this game
bro I I don't know if this is a hot take
I think it's better than breath of the
well I think it looked again i' I've
played like 1 hour of this game yeah I
felt like I booted it up and I was like
oh [__] it's just [__] breath of the
wild right when you start off for sure
yeah because it's the exact same map
yeah and then it's like uh they had the
banjo kazes thing banjo kazes nuts and
bols they had oh you build your own [__]
just Lego again it's just Lego yeah
that's just Joey went from playing Lego
in real life to Lego virtually I know I
was kind of I kind of was really excited
for them to kind of hopefully go in a
bit of a different direction almost I
think they did though because what I
thought was kind of Genius was the fact
that yes the the main map of highy roll
is pretty much exactly the same as
birath of the wild uh but with because
they add completely new power Ops now
the way to Traverse this like familiar
land becomes completely new to you and
also like with the sky islands which is
like a whole new area
full as do you want to know what put me
off into playing this already it's the
underground section man why I don't know
it just I you know sometimes you look at
a video game and there are some levels
that you really Vibe with and really
like and then sometimes you just get
through a level even though you [__]
hated it that's just me with Underground
Level and Cave levels you know love cave
levels you love cave levels I [__] I
hate it man it's so rare you can get you
can make like Gamers lose any sense
Direction caves are so I hate that so
much but that's that's like you can't
get that anywhere else right like and I
don't want to go [__] caving in real
life but I the kingdom did that to the
tea as well because when you go into the
underground first it is Pitch Black oh
my God that that's everything I hate so
you just have to like blindly TR like
you know when you're you're like you're
like 11 11 years old and you're like I
can get through this Pokemon cave
without Flash yeah and then you start
like the biggest mistake of your life
and it's terrifying cuz you're like I
might not ever get out of here like I I
I love trying to recreate that feeling
cuz you'll never get that feeling ever
again that Zoom when you real to Smart
you're too smart you know that you're
not going to that Doom when you realize
you have no Escape ropes just like well
I guess I'm here forever now caving to
me is caving to me in a video game is
just anxiety simulator love and I
[__] hate that oh my God I prefer
that because I rather experience that
anxiety in a video game where there are
no Stakes as opposed to real life you
know let me tell let me tell you why let
me tell you why I hate cave levels in
every video game the completion is to me
it's just like okay I'm going to
systematically explore everything in
this cave you take like five steps
you're like okay here's a wall I've
explored this area you turn around
you're like wait this isn't where I
started off and then you get completely
lost so that little side of me that is
that it says like I want to I want to
completely explore this area I just get
completely lost and I can't
systematically explore the way I like to
explore levels okay then you might like
the way that tears of the kingdom does
then because in tear of the Kingdom
there are like several holes in the main
world where you can like jump into to
access different parts of the
underground and at first when you jump
in it's like you look at the map and
it's just completely pitch black but the
way that the game kind of forces you to
like navigate and explore it is that
like kind of like with shrines in breath
of the wild you'd see something in the
distance and you go oh that's a place
that I can just head towards and the and
the underground kind of does same thing
it's not quite shrines it's like some
other thing but when you get to it it
lights up a certain area surrounding
that checkpoint and so gradually you
open up more of the map of the
underground so it's a really ingenious
way of like you know giving you that
sense of dread that Conor was saying but
also giving you like a motivation to
step into that dread and I think that's
like one thing that breath of the wild
didn't quite have because breath of the
wild is like kind of you go to a tower
and then immediately everything is
opened up and then it's just you know
right for the yeah Assassin's Creed
style right but the underground I
thought was like an interesting addition
to that because it it's a lot harder
than the main did you enjoy did you
enjoy the underground section I did
actually I I fully completed the map as
well because it actually motivated me to
like I want to see what this entire
place looks like yeah I think the the
the problem I'm having this year with
gaming is that even though I'm you know
I'm very fortunate and I can stream
games full time I still don't have
enough time to play all the games I want
to play yeah mhm and like you look at
like some of the best games this of this
year a lot of them are [__] long
games breath of the wild is an 80 hour
Game Y uh G three as well is like
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
hours and it's like I I recognize that
Zelda TW of the kingdom is probably
another absolute Banger they've knocked
out of the park but I was you know when
I when I I bought the game I booted it
up for hour and I was like you know what
these 80 hours even though people be
like oh he plays [__] SU game or he
plays [__] jump King it's like yeah
but like I only lose like 10 10 hours
from doing that or like you know 10
hours here and there and it's like I
think for me personally I didn't want to
kind of experience a very similar
experience to breath of the wild but
maybe with a Different Twist on it i'
felt like I'd kind of got my f of that
and that world and I was kind of hoping
sorry SP everywhere it's kind of hoping
for me I wanted like an kind of a
different experience and and when I was
looking at the building mechanics and
the new worlds I was like I doesn't
really feel like enough for me to want
to get reinvested sink at least 80 hours
into this world and do all over again I
was like I'd rather just spend my time
gaming on other stuff this year that's
fair and so but then if you say that
people like oh you to [__] play Zelda
you you're not a real gamer and it's
like well you know you
okay congrats you want no gamer congrats
you wanted to [__] play I mean you're
arguing with that you can't win against
you know no I I mean listen Zelda fans
are Zelda fans and they it's like it's
like you know just it's like telling
wine snobs you're like you know maybe I
don't want to spend $300 on a wine like
what do you mean it's the best fanciest
wine of all agrees it's the best it's
like well it's just not for me maybe I
just don't want this again chill the
[__] out you know solid game that came
out this year that's short as [__] like
10 hours [__] the new Super Mario RPG
remake dude I want to play that that
game is short as hell i' I beat it in a
day everyone everyone is complimenting
it for being a a 10 12h hour game
everyone's like thank [__] God I make
an RPG game where you cut out all the
[__] yeah I feel like we need more
of that if anything we need more I
actually forgot how short it was when I
beat it I was like oh yeah the original
is also this length it just felt longer
because I was a dumb child and I
couldn't go through the game as quickly
as I can now but yeah it's a [__]
awesome game like I was debating between
putting that there instead of uh birth
of the wild but they're both you you
should play that you can easily I really
really want to do that uh because I've
heard nothing but good things and again
the the main thing I've heard about it
is that it cuts out all the grinding and
all the dumb [__] Y and you literally
don't have to grind yeah which is like I
I think I there should be an option
where I never have to do a side quest or
grind in an RPG I I firmly believe that
well like you don't have to do a side
quest no I know but like I I shouldn't
have to like also you don't have to
grind if you're gamer
enough okay first of all some some RPGs
will just straight up be like you do not
you are nowhere near level up for this
you're like but I've done every Mission
up until this point yeah but those RPGs
are usually ass anyway yeah those are
normally those are normally like the
older RPGs now if anything uh I feel
like RPGs modern day uh have gotten
better in not making sure you have to
grind but the annoying part is just the
natural getting from point A to point B
you are just going to Natural I feel I
feel modern jrpgs now they put grinding
in as an option for people who can't out
strategize the game like normally W no
they can like legit like you know like
there's a lot of uh games like smaller
jrpgs that I played this year that were
quite new and I realized that like I was
getting through these games a lot faster
not because they're any easier but
because they made it easier for you to
figure out strategically how you can get
past these difficult points whereas the
older jrpgs your only option was to just
be at a higher level because there were
less options I have a question
completely unrelated to RPGs um Persona
does persona have grinding
Persona why is it so godamn long it's
like 200 hours long right because the
story is long yeah they need to chill
the [__] out Persona 3 remake next year
[__] let's go I'm so excited let's go
yeah Persona is kind it's it's almost
you're going to hate this it's almost
like a vision over at some points so
many different mechanics but it's you
know it's present the story's presented
you to you in like kind of a visual
novel form esque it's cuz you know
whenever I watch memes or videos about
persona it's like it looks so [__]
hype it's so fun all the menuing and
it's so cool and whenever I watch
streams that go in it'd be [__]
resident sleeper dude I go in there it's
[__] guy clicking a for 15 hours and
I'm like happened something Happ happen
stop [__] trying to [__] the teacher
I mean it does happen it's just from
from the from point A to point B is just
a long more about iter Persona is almost
like five different games in one okay
okay uh so breath of the Wild Nothing
breath of the wild breath of the boring
is Pete calls it
bre Pete's got to think of a new new
name for teas of the Kingdom teas of the
games I don't know the game what's the
Middle top uh so I just put concerts
just in general cuz I realized thinking
back to this year I went to a fuckload
of music concerts I think I saw about 15
bands this year holy [__] um two can't
believe you missed the Geeks plus
Christmas party because of another
[__] concert dude I had to go excuse
me excuse dude I had to see TK live and
he was [__] insane you know he's
almost 50 is the guy who did the is it
the guy did the unv did you do unravel
live no he didn't what I would ask for a
refund no because I'd like him his band
I don't well [__] you I'm there for the
song I I went there for the band I'm
there for the beeps kidding no he didn't
do any like solo stuff but like it's
actually cuz like I've been following
this band like for a really really long
time because my cousin actually used to
be one of their photographers when they
was still like an indie band up in
saitom so like I'd known about them for
a really long time and then when I saw
that they did the psychopath opening I
was just like oh [__] that's my band
right there yo like it's I was having a
real hipster moment
but then I think our coffee are here
right might be
upstairs yeah they were like quite a
while ago right sorry to interruped
that's okay uh but yeah so like going to
see D was like big big uh you know
bucket list band that I wanted to go see
absolutely [__] insane I don't know
how TK can scream like that live and not
burst his [__] how long is he singing
about an hour and a half [__] hour and a
half set yeah and he was going [__]
ham and it was really funny because the
basist is like uh this girl called M and
she's this tiny tiny [__] Japanese
woman it makes her bass look like a
[__] double Bas and uh and like in
the middle they had like a little uh I
guess uh you know just MC moment where
they would just like kind of talk to the
crowd and I guess they were selling
merch and I guess they do all their
merch themselves because they're still
kind of a smaller band and Mio I I I
swear like mioko legit might have been
like the model for Boi cuz that's how
she kind of was like on stage she was
this really [__] quiet timid girl and
she's just like we have
shirts and a hat is this a a thing in
Japanese concerts cuz I've only been to
one but they like stopped the show
halfway to do like a merch presentation
yeah I think it's a Japanese thing it's
like like wait what cuz I I've seen that
quite a bit it's also a Japanese thing
where they have to like every song has
to have like an anecdote to go with that
song you know what I mean it's like that
[__] Taylor Swift like every time she
introduces a new song there has to be
some kind of [__] story attached to
it yeah yeah uh no but actually didn't
do that much of that um but yeah like I
I think I knocked off quite a bit of
like bucket list bands this year like I
saw Maximum the Hormone which were
[__] insane I saw baby metal which
were [__] insane Bring Me The Horizon
Simple Plan like ton of what been the
best con you've been to this year then
oh that's hard did bring me to the rise
and sing the gigachad song they did they
did [__] yeah did they do the Giga song
they did did they talk about the gig
they didn't talk about oh but it was
very obvious like cuz the moment it came
on all the foreigners were
like actually I think that was the first
song they played oh yeah they opened up
with that which is [__] awesome but
I'd say I I I'd have to say probably the
best one was surprisingly baby metal oh
[__] like cuz like we were they were at
they were at this like metal festival we
went to the bring me to the Horizon
festival and there was like a ton of
like you know obviously big metal bands
like bring me and like Max the hormone
but there were also some like really
small Japanese bands as well that were
there which was kind of cool for bring
me to like include and like kind of show
off because like I looked up some of
these bands and they were they had like
800 monthly listeners on Spotify or
something there's tiny tiny band they
find these guys I don't know because
like all the bands they invited thank
you all the bands they invited uh like
Ollie from Bring Me The Horizon were
like personal fans of them and they
wanted to invite them out so I'm like
that was really cool like notion of them
but baby metal it was like I've never
seen that wholesome of a mosh pit happen
before cuz when they played uh gimme
chocolate which is like you know their
big song and a Circle of Death started
happening normally in like a metal
concert Circle of Death you know people
are like throwing punches like you know
[__] pushing people around like it's
called a circle of death for a reason
but the bring me but the give me
chocolate Circle of Death everyone was
just running around high-fiving everyone
and I was like
y wait why why would I want to get
beaten up because it's a metal concert I
don't want to get beaten up that's what
happens in a metal concert Mosh Pit man
what the heck a high five Circle of
Death it was really funny all these like
like a slice of life version all these
Japanese dudes just [__] going yay to
everyone outside the circle sounds like
sounds like what would happen in a Kon
concert yeah legit it was like a Kon
concert but yeah uh so that's why I just
included all music concerts cuz right I
[__] L my experience so if I'm seeing
this correctly Joey yeah you've finally
started Hunter Hunter is that manga or
anime
manga so I've I've caught up to the
manga of Hunter Hunter uh I finally sat
down thought you know what caught up
caught up we spoke about this in the
previous episode yeah we've talked about
it you read The Boat Part I've read The
Boat
Part you just hurry the [__] up I know I
I get it now yeah it's like and I wish I
didn't because now I'm sitting there
being like great another show I have to
wait for I it's like it's the the Hun
Hunter mango has reached a point where
I'm like this is a joke now you're
you're actively trying to like just
never finish this like so come on what's
what's your favorite Arc yeah probably
cim ant cim
ant I think the Cima ant Arc is is gets
way too much hate I think it's yeah
that's what I didn't understand why is
cim and now that I know the full concept
because it's so long and Anime only fans
watch it and it's like 80 episodes out
of the 140 odd so it's it's most of it
and I think most people who who know of
hun Hunter have only watched the anime
right and I I can understand why they
think hey this is really [__] long I
mean it was long in the manga as well
but it was also [__] hyp [__] I think
ant has some of the best peaks of Hunter
Hunter oh totally I I feel anime flat
out yeah peaks of anime flat out I think
my favorite Arc of Hunter Hunter is prob
oh this is so hard Greed Island I really
[__] like Greed Island Island a Greed
Island isn't that like a really
unpopular one that's a really unpopular
one uh I really the people who like it
really like it I've noticed the thing I
loved about greed it's not my favorite
Arc I think yorkin is my favorite Arc uh
just because like that Arc is so dense
where it's rare that you see an arc
where every episode you're like holy
[__] that was a banger you put on the
next episode you're like holy [__] this
was also a banger and it just keeps
delivering every single I think the one
thing I didn't like about the
auctioneering arc it was just it's it's
a bit of a nitpick but like I just
didn't like in I don't know how it is in
the anime but in the manga there's like
three or four maybe five chapters back
to back where gone and Kida are learning
to like the ins and outs of like
auctioning and I'm just like am I
reading a manga or am I reading a
textbook about auctioning like I get
like you want to like teach me this
stuff to but like I just want you to get
to the auction sometimes you turn the
the page in Hunter Hunter and you're
just greeted with a novel and you're
like you're like why did you bother
drawing I remember in the why you even
bother in Greed Island when they first
like introducing all the card system in
the manga there's like six pages where
Togashi just shows all the cards that
tutal in Greed Island with like all the
text and [__] and it's like and then by
the end of Greed Island I realized I'm
like I think about 80% % of these cars
just never showed up yeah the thing I
really liked the thing I really liked
about Greed Island is that that was the
arc that convince me that nen is just
the best power system just the fact that
you can create an entire world out of
this malleable system I was like holy
[__] this is insane of course yes maybe
it's a bit self-indulgent I don't kind
of give I kind of don't give a [__] just
because of how interesting and how inde
depth this power system is that this AR
kind of like displayed the depth and the
limits of what you could do with
something like this also not to give
spoilers but like I'd kind of like
already slightly heard about like what
happens like me yeah but when I got to
the manga like the bad part in the manga
I still
cried that death is he crazy is one of
the best villains in anime manga period
such a good villain for that Arc
especially so yeah I I finally see the
hype now I get it I knew I was going to
like it as I've been saying but now I
actually know the full context now I
have to watch for met Alchemist you
watch hunter hunter or red Hunter Hunter
yeah octopath traveler 2o yeah you liked
it that much I thought this was [__]
amazing and especially coming from the
fact that I also played octopath
traveler 1 I realized just how much of a
like just a missed opportunity octopath
traveler 1 was because like in in terms
of the actual gameplay it's not that
much different to octopath travel one um
like to explain octopath travel for
anyone who doesn't know basically it's a
jrpg uh Square Enix but you follow eight
protagonists and all of their stories
all at the same time um and as you go
through the world you unlock different
parts of the story of each of the
characters and then it gets to a final
ending octopath octopath exactly but
octopath traveler 2 I think for one like
the music is [__] god tier like I
think I'm actually going to try and go
to the concert next year that they have
and also the stories and characters were
just infinitely more interesting than
the first one cuz I think that was the
biggest struggle with me finishing
octopath traveler 1 was that like I
wasn't invested in every single
character whereas which made it
difficult when you're trying to go
through the story elements of every
single character but with octopath
traveler 2 every character I was like
Banger Banger Banger every single story
line was just so engaging and the ending
as well is just like it's hard as [__]
like I had to grind the [__] out of it
for the end but it was a really really
just like satisfying I think I put in
about 100 into this one but it was such
a good game and I think it's like kind
of slept on just because I feel a lot of
people were kind of just thrown off from
playing octopath traveler 1 but so if
you didn't like octopath traveler 1 for
those reasons I would highly recommend
you play octop travel 2 this one that
was badly reviewed or was it the first
one first one okay yeah the second one
actually I think is like all like
critically acclaimed like everybody
agrees that compared to one two is like
infinitely better it's always better
when the first one's better than the
second cuz it's easier to to tell people
on the it's kind of sad to be like hey
play an 80 hour game for the next one
that's good yeah well luckily you don't
have to play one to play two yeah but
everyone says that a lot of the time and
it's sometimes it's like but I but I
feel like I should no I think that with
two there is literally no connection
okay at all the only connection is that
it's the same type of gameplay but in
terms of characters and story it's all
different uh so yeah freaking great also
like so many like really really
high-profile anime voice actors are in
the Japanese version of this like it's
crazy
likeu like all these like huge names I'm
just like oh I recognize that voice I
recognize that voice I recognize that
voice so yeah really really solid I'd
say it's probably my favorite J better
about this compared to number one I
think it just made the stories a little
more coherent because the way you play
octopath you're obviously not going to
follow the chapter of one character
simultaneously like you you see one part
of the story of a character and then
you're going to move on to another part
of a different character story so
octopot traveler one the way they wrote
each of the story lines kind of made it
a little bit difficult to like remind
yourself like oh yeah where was I in the
story with this particular character
again cuz I was busy doing three other
character stories whereas with two they
made the story a lot more streamlined so
that it just made sense especially with
like the progression in the game it just
felt more cohesive in general and the
music and the visuals they just like up
that as well so it's yeah really really
solid jrpg okay uh hell's Paradise
hell's Paradise your only anime I had to
put an anime on there is this is this
the anime version this is the anime
version you had to put an anime on there
you didn't you didn't have to put an
anime come on the fact that it's Hill's
Paradise I'm like look I like this is
this is like my favorite 8 out of 10
show of the year I really great time but
like not a masterpiece I think that's
why I put it on there because I just had
a really fun time
watching it wasn't like I'm not going to
say it's like a 10 out of 10 Masterpiece
or anything but like just it was just
nice to see like a no [__] No Frills
shown in yeah I I I knew it was going to
be an extremely solid show after episode
one and I didn't think it was going to
be it was going to go to like some crazy
like plot twist depths or anything like
that but I just knew it was going to be
a fun time I just like the fact that
there was just like almost zero filler
to it which is always nice you know
because it's like one when Once one
thing happens like boom here comes the
next thing here comes the next thing and
I'm like oh okay I'm actually like
engaged now you think you're going to
watch season 2 yeah probably I I mean
I've also read ahead on the manga as
well going to lie it start like I really
liked the beginning of Hell's Paradise I
love the it was basically what gave me
what the dark conent in Hunter Hunter
hasn't given the sense of Doom the sense
of Doom exploration anything can [__]
you up mhm and then the power system got
introduced and I'm like ah okay this is
this is kind of it just turns it's kind
of starting to feel like it's turning
into like a more traditional generic
shown in and I'm like oh I don't know if
it's interesting enough to keep my
attention anime only or Manga this is
the anime only so you you know you know
the end of the anime where introdu that
they started introducing that power
system and then of course all the
protagonists master it in like a day and
I'm like and I'm like okay uh I just
[__] with that guy who chopped his arm
off I just like that guy he's fun oh
he's just fun to watch yeah I mean
that's the thing Samurai guy yeah that
was fun all the side characters are just
so likable and just so insane and it's
like again like you know I definitely
have like qualms with it for sure but I
just had a really enjoyable time
watching I think hottest anime character
of the year was
Yuzu the uh the uh samur Samurai Girl oh
the ninja girl yeah dude she on my
knees I I pretty damn hot when I look
back at the year's hottest characters
I'm like
yeah I was like when they gave for the
power to what was it
secrete sweat or some [__] like that I'm
like oh god oh they know what they doing
reminds you of that Meme with the like
the guy on like a Tik Tok holding a
cigar in a suit I don't know why it's
just just like me and the boys getting
ready to appreciate it's like oh gosh
definitely for sure yeah so I think like
out of all the ones like I think for me
this is like how many anime did you
watch this year out of curiosity oh I
wish I I should start keeping track I'm
not going to but I should yeah I should
keep track I'd say maybe about 10 10
oh [__] yeah I've watched a decent
amount like just the ones that I think
I'm going to get into that interest me
like I'm not going to watch all the
[__] is like [__] that but like yeah
I think just out of all the ones I watch
like this one I just was like yeah hell
yeah you know it kind of reminded it
kind of took me back to like that time
where like I could just turn my brain
off and watch a nice show all what about
uh nonsense I mean nonsense is pretty
self-expand yeah I mean I put nonsense
there but like just congratulations on
your cyber Punk launch by the thank you
very much uh like the I'm just mostly
talking about just like Japanese street
wear in this case because it's not just
the nonsense you put yourself
to if I'm going to sell out to anyone
I'm going to sell out to myself but uh
yeah just like obviously from doing the
nonsense stuff hardcore this year I just
got more into like the different sects
of like Japanese fashion and like
Japanese streetwear stuff so like yeah
just in general I've just yeah got into
clothing a lot more which I think just
makes sense by the way the stuff is
still available I would hope you have
you would have gotten into clothing lot
more considering you now own a clothing
company Joey would have been pretty
worrying I'll take the whole collection
please thank you Joe thank you yeah
still Pokémon go yeah what the [__]
is3 Pokemon go to the this is this is
you reaching to the bottom of the
Bargain Bin guy will literally do
anything but watch anime I like what
what else can I do this year oh God
Pokemon go okay okay okay with this one
right I saw this [__] video of you
playing a 4 400 Day game what's going on
yeah why why AR you why are you not
watching anime come on
[Music]
because cuz nothing good came out 2023
right just kidding but yeah okay with
Pokémon go uh because we did so much
[__] traveling this year like more
than at least I did anyway I don't know
about you guys but we I think all three
of us we did a lot of traveling what are
you talking about I was there with it
for most year yeah but I mean I also
went to a lot of places myself in the
same places Joey yeah but like I think
because you know I went traveling so
freaking much and you know uh my friend
like recently got back into Pokémon go
like earlier this year uh and I saw him
playing it and I was like oh has like
anything new changed at all cuz I Haven
played the game in since like basically
the beginning of Co when like you
couldn't go outside uh and he was like
oh yeah and he showed me all the new
stuff that they had and I was like oh
wow this is actually like a playable
game again so I picked it up and it was
great because during the travels you can
get like region exclusive [__] so I was
like well it makes sense I guess while
I'm traveling I might well have
something to do so I picked up Pokémon
go again and uh it's actually a really
[__] fun game again cuz before like
they they just basically were like the
vanilla version of this game was just
like go out into the world walk around
catch Pokemon complete your decks blah
blah blah but now they've added like you
know rocket grunts they've added raids
they've added uh [__] [__] what else
like Bas like a ton of new [__] that
actually makes it so that you don't have
to go outside all the time to like still
interact with the game yeah and it just
made sense for me considering that again
I traveled so much I was like well I'm
going to get all the exclusive [__]
going to be fun again and now that
they've added like pretty much up to the
latest generation there's like over a
thousand Pokémon now you can catch so
there's just more longevity in the game
as well so yeah that's uh that's what I
got into this year I guess uh that's
about
it I am I a pretty varied list I am a
child is what we figured out yes well
good to know that you're rediscovering
your in a 13-year-old y as we all are as
I'm approaching 30 I'm like God damn I
want to go back take me back take me
back take me back
please all right shall we move on to the
next one then who's next you want to go
next Conor sure yeah I'll M yet this
episode is sponsored by boxer Did you
procrastinate on your Christmas items I
bet you did I know you did it couldn't
be me listen it happens to the best of
us Jerry but you don't have to show up
empty-handed instead you can pretend you
have your [__] together you can give
them a cute little card which says that
you have ever so thoughtfully gifted
them a boxu snackbox subscription that's
the best gift I could ask you already
know boxu is the premium Japanese snack
the premium God they work with family
businesses all over Japan and deliver a
new theme of authentic treats every
single month but what you maybe didn't
know Gamers is that they have gift
options as well Christmas is safe you
can sign your favorite person up to
receive Three 6 or 12 months worth of
their epic snack C duration this month
we got OSU fortunes OSU is what in Japan
we call the beginning of the year what
you have there is fried rice crackers
miso flavored smell that smell that and
of course Connor has the Japan famous
budak Ganda a lovely chocolate so guys
if you have anyone in your life that
loves Japan or just loves awesome food
why not give them the gift of boxu so to
get $15 off your own Japanese boxu
snackbox and support our Channel use
code trash box.com that's Bo
kk.com that is Bok
k.com with our code trash for $15 off
your first order thank you very much to
boxy for sponsoring us today back to the
episode I'll I'll go right away and I
I'll explain I put the H zachi film on
here because the more I like like sit
Yeah the more I sit after watching this
movie The More I really [__] with it I
still need to watch it yeah initially
when I left the theater I was kind of
like okay whatever but the mor I've just
gone on about my life The more I've
thought about that movie a lot more
which I feel like a lot of movies don't
do a lot of a lot of movies when I watch
them I consume them and I think nothing
of them until someone reminds me they
exist yeah this is one that I keep
thinking about um I don't know what that
that that says about the movie but it's
really stuck with me what what are you
thinking about it I don't know I I I was
really really really and I know this is
such a uh usual thing to say but the
music and the visuals were so [__]
good as always um well that's something
can normally expect from a gibli film
yeah I know um Jo he says she don't miss
me he just doesn't Fu does just be bad
at something I hate how talented he is
and it's and it's and it's annoying cuz
I really really don't enjoy ha Miaki as
a person as much yeah uh just well just
because the way that he kind of the way
he talks about things and it's dude I'm
still angry about how he was mean to his
son even even though some people online
online find that like really funny and
like so [__] based and it's like what
a [__] awful dad but uh but godamn he
makes bangers godamn this film is really
[__] good and I really can't wait to
watch this dobbed again cuz [__]
Robert Patterson looks like he just it
just looked like he he just you know was
in Twilight once and took it personally
and now he's just he's on a mission to
be good in everything ever uh so super
stoked about it but honestly I I I I
haven't watched many gibl films but it's
definitely my favorite one out of all of
them I like Spirited Away wow really but
then again I didn't grow up with
Spirited Away I watched it for the first
time this year as well you did yeah I
didn't know that yeah if I ever said
that I watched it before I lied because
I was self-conscious about not watching
it uh but I have now watched it wait so
what did you okay now I'm curious as
someone who just discovered Spirit of
away in 2023 what did you think of it I
enjoyed it has it aged well um I thought
it was good I felt that because there
was so many uh so many visual metaphors
and a lot of different kind of uh what's
the word for this I forgot how to
explain this because my English
explanations are bad um a lot of
different messages and themes that I
couldn't pick up on on my first viewing
that I I then had to like when I read
more about the movie and I realized I
missed a bunch of things cuz there just
so much going on especially like
visually there's just like they would I
I would read about the what each visual
representation meant and I was like oh
[__] I had no way of figuring that out
my first watch yeah yeah yeah and you
know I appreciated that but at the same
time I felt like I really enjoyed the
boy and the Heron uh I also went into it
knowing [__] nothing I started
everyone in Japan yeah we did not have
any marketing for all I know is that
they had that one sick sketch of the
bird and I was kind of like all right
let's find out um and also I won't lie
for me personally it was really fun and
satisfying getting to watch film in
Japanese uh and understanding the entire
plot hell yeah I was super stoked about
that and I felt like the only character
I couldn't understand was the bird
sometimes because you'd be
like and he T really fast I like hold on
okay let me try and like back up real
quick but everyone else I could
understand pretty well and I was really
hyped about it and honestly it was a fun
time I I really really want to rewatch
it again just so I can kind of
articulate how I feel about it much
better but it really really stuck with
me and I feel like that deserves
something no a damn it's the one
Japanese film that's just not in cinemas
anymore I guess yeah right yeah and you
know and I think back to other films
I've watched this year and I think I
enjoyed Oppenheimer more which is why
it's on this list as well I want put one
movie on this list and they're putting
two but opam was probably and I feel so
bad putting it up there cuz it's like
feels like such a copout no I mean I
watched Oppenheimer as well it was
[__] fantastic it is a great film
John MC four came out this year which I
also loved yeah I surprised you didn't
put John Wick that on here which was I
feel like I've watched I've watched at
least every like nearly I want to say
80% of the theatrical releases of
English films in Japan right um and I've
been trying to watch almost every film
that's coming out did OB come out in
Japan it didn't I watched it in LA but
it's coming out this it's coming out in
2024 oh it is I thought they were just
never going so it is coming out and I
there's a lot of other movies that
didn't get theatrical releases that have
been really highly rated and I really
want to watch but in terms of theatrical
releases this is the one I probably
enjoyed most it does help that I also
watched in like the [__] best theater
I've ever been in in my life um it was
just a good film and agree I just wish
that we could I could somehow pause a
film and go piss in the theater because
I I had to I had to like I tactically
think about when to piss yeah and that's
the only bad thing about it but other
than that you know it was such a [__]
good film that's why like when I'm in
the cinemas I don't drink a single drop
of water so by the end of the film just
like was drink craft beers and I oh you
they had craft beers in it was craft
beers food I was I got wings I got
bottomless popcorn bro only in America
man
I'm telling you Oppenheimer was the one
film where I wanted like an eight course
meal during it I was the only
[__] in that whole theater
eating and I I'd chew into the saler it
was and it would make like a bone
crunching sound it was so [__] good
eating eating a juicy ass buffalo
chicken wing when he's talking to
Einstein it was like this is what life
was meant to be I I still love how hype
I got you how how hype people get when
you just see Einstein yeah why it was
kind
of I I watched bobie as well and uh
there was the whole you know bobie
versus no but I thought Oppenheimer was
I still hadn't watched Barbie it's fun
it's a really good fil heard Barbie is
more political than Oppenheimer is
that's what I heard a weird way I heard
that was a meme I don't know how true it
is actually but it's like dude it's it's
crazy how you know you know we you when
we head to S we about one piece we were
like w one piece is political and
obviously we played it up a bit and
people were like like meing on us we
like we didn't we didn't know one piece
of political obviously I know that one
piece of political but I was you know I
think all of us were like playing it up
to kind of H have the conversation enter
that kind of thing and there are a lot
of media that are very very political
the people um uh and and I guess I'll
talk about this when we talk about Final
Fantasy but like I I've because I've
played Final Fantasy and people talk
about the new one they're like man I
hope they don't get political about it
and I'm like the whole game is super
political the whole series is political
and the so many so much media is super
political inherently because of the
themes they're tackling and people like
they just ignore it because it's not
what they want to deal with but I felt
like Bobby people were like man I just
don't like political it's like oh [__]
off you watch so much political [__] but
suddenly when it's about a topic that
makes you slightly uncomfortable it's
too political now literally every Final
Fantasy is Big military organization
takes over
corrupt organization so many game so
many games so much media you consume is
way more political than people like to
admit but the moment it's about some a
kind of politics that they kind of
really don't want to be don't want to be
faced with that's when they start being
like and I felt bobie uh unfortunately
was one of those where it was like yeah
well I think I think there's this goes
like two ways right to to play Devil's
Advocate a lot of people would just want
to watch media for like to escape the
Liv absolutely uh to to Es as escapism
to escape the Liv they're living right
now and obviously there are a lot of
different political things in pretty
much baked into every single piece of
media that you consume but some stories
might hit a little too close to home
than other stories I think the most like
recent one I can think of that I watched
recently was you know you watch Pluto
right yeah the one where they are had a
whole storyline about going to this
Middle Eastern
country to look for uh robots of mass
destruction that may or may not have
been in development that was yeah that
was a little was a little I was like I
was like H okay we couldn't have we
couldn't have thought of a slightly
different story like I was I was like I
I I have no doubt this is not inspired
by real events at all or real politics
you know yeah and I think that's why one
piece and like FAL fantasy do really
well is that there the messages are real
but they're not grounded in anything
that you can like be like oh they're
talking about this they're also more
generalized right so it's harder to like
pinpoint like oh they're referencing
this particular thing and the only thing
I can probably in that sense that people
didn't like about it's probably because
barie sometimes would just straight up
talk to you about what it was trying to
tell you which I think is still on the
nose it's it's and also you know I felt
like the message was getting across
anyway sometimes without needing to tell
people I think the moment you're telling
the audience hey this is the problem or
hey this is the politics we're talking
about it's like okay well got to figured
that out myself yeah I I I think I think
it's inherently what the message is and
how you portray that message some some
some pieces of media do it really well
like you know sometimes the best the
best ones are shows like southp or
Always Sunny where they kind of don't
lean towards one message or another
they're more of just like making you
think about the entire
situation yeah in itself South's
interesting South sometimes okay and
sometimes really [__] bad depending
on what they want to do but it is very
funny seeing people be like look Eric
Cartman's right guys he was right all
along everything is two o and it's like
do you understand who Eric kman is and
what the role he fills you completely
missing the point you are the the fact
that you're taking things agree with
Eric means that you're wrong okay I
would like to say massive achievement
for 2023 of getting Connor to put a
[__] Final Fantasy game we we have we
have gotten Conor into jrpgs we did it
guys yeah uh yeah Final Fantasy I
honestly the series here I'll put but I
just put seven I play Play Seven yeah I
played seven and eight which did you
prefer seven seven yeah the visuals have
not done that well though admittedly
admittedly I played it with some mods
that upscaled the
backgrounds and some other things I'm
telling you man I I know some people are
like it's a basz to play it with mods
but some of these mods are so [__]
good I played the 60fps mod which is
amazing on PC um and I played it with uh
speed up as well uh yeah and also there
was a widescreen mod you just expand the
backgrounds especially if like you're in
an area where all the background is
already like rendered in it just fill
out the screen which just makes it a
little easier to to I mean it looks
looks nicer all the mods I used I really
really really felt were very faithful um
and because I I what I did is when I was
putting all these mods on I was like
looking between I kept starting the game
with and without mods to see if it was
like too Gody or too ugly with the mods
but all of them I really really thought
made it look really nice okay I need to
know now your opinion on this now that
you've played Seven all right [__] Mary
kill yui aith or Tifa
uh I'm going to let you know right now
there is no correct answer I I will in
your opinion [__]
youthi B kill aith and marry Tifa
based what
okay all right so that's the cannon
answer right yeah that is that is the
correct answer actually uh yeah I mean I
feel like it's I mean I I I was really
happy that I somehow went
26 27 years uh it might be 27 years by
the time this is out I don't know what
this um without [__] knowing anything
about this game I I I knew zov bad and
that's about it that's all I knew yeah
yeah um which almost know you didn't
know big spoiler I didn't I actually
didn't I know some someone dies but I
didn't know who or when right okay uh so
that must have hit you when it happened
I was kind of shocked cuz I was like
wait I we could have revived everyone
else
standing there like Phoenix down Phoenix
down I I really really enjoyed it uh it
was kind of fun cuz I felt that
throughout the 30 odd hours 36 hours I
was playing it there was never a point
where I felt like I had to grind which
is again one of my big pluses for an RPG
did you have turbo mode on uh there was
turbo mode that I used for some battles
like Random Encounters when I trying to
trying to get through a place yeah yeah
uh but through most of it I had it off
it was just when I was traversing or
going around a place yeah um but I yeah
I read every piece of dialogue I didn't
skip any cartoons uh it was very fun I
really enjoyed the story I think one one
praise that I can give it uh that I feel
that I've played other games that don't
other RPGs that don't do this you have
to bear in Mind by the way I was want to
peed about this my my first RPG that I
ever beat right was [__] blue dragon
on the Xbox 360 oh yeah I remember you
telling me this yeah so my exposure to
RPGs was dog [__] so I thought they were
all like that cuz you know that was from
uh I forgot his name the guy who made
founded or Square Enix H sorry uh Square
soft and then left to make uh Mist
Walker something like that and then he
made Lost Odyssey which was very highly
acclaimed the first one he made was blue
dragon with collaboration with uh T Tor
Armor's Tom company and so this is this
supposed to be like one of the goat
games and it was just whatever it was
such a [__] game not I'm just going to
say it was [__] and even likey old could
tell visually it was fine but the battle
system was clunky and it was boring it
last too long the one thing that was
amazing about Final Fantasy 7 that I
really appreciated it is that it always
felt like the story was moving even when
it was like bombarding me with
convoluted story and dialogue I never
felt like I wasn't progressing yeah uh
and I never felt like i' hit a wall of
like this is dumb why am I doing this
you never felt checked out of the story
right no no and the the material system
which is like their their system of
managing magic I guess or whatever was
really [__] good I really enjoyed it
it was just a great game what a [__]
fun game it's a great game think it's
age well absolutely I think the how you
think the story went uh it was a little
convoluted at times right but that seems
part of the course for jrpgs and
Japanese media in general I think I
think the story is the thing that has
aged the the finest
in7 um I the thing that I didn't like
about it is that and this is more so I
don't know how much this is maybe squar
soft trying to cash in because they've
made so much media adjacent to the Final
Fantasy 7 Universe it was very [__]
annoying having everyone be like play
this game watch advent children do this
do this play uh crisis play crisis call
do this and it's like shut up shut up
let me play the [__] game let me play
the game are you going to play the
remakes I I'm going to wait till all
three are out yeah second one's coming
out next year I know I'm starting I'm
starting my I'm restarting my journey on
the remakes I'm have you played the
original I haven't no you just play the
original you just play the original the
original kind of [__] loser play the
original kind of feel like I'd rather
play the remakes now that they're coming
out I don't know I really enjoy well
they're apparently going to change some
of the story in the remixes right yeah
if they do I'll go
back I'm I'm kind of enjoying it like
going through it as it is kind of like
coming out now um the next one you go to
play Conor is 10 well I'm going to I I
want to play nine and 10 nine is all
nine what n this is so this is this is
the thing I hate about Final Fantasy
when I talk about it depending on who I
ask I I get like completely different
opinions someone will be like six is the
best thing of all time some be like okay
see what I mean and I'll be like ah 10's
ey but Nine's really where it's at nine
has like n know I don't know anyone
who's talks about nine nine has like a
cult fan base like people who have
played nine like [__] love nine I've
played it's a good Final Fantasy but I
think if you want like the kind of Next
Generation Final Fantasy game to
experience like 10 is like the solid one
yeah one thing that I when I was playing
this that I was kind of sitting there
realizing uh because this game came out
in
199 uh which is one year after Mario 64
came out and that was revolutionary when
that came out I was thinking like I'm
this is never going to happen again
where you play a game like this that
just absolutely blows your mind and
redefines everything oh yeah it was this
game in ocar of time that were the ones
that were just like this is the future
of gaming and it's like playing it I was
like I would like I I could understand I
was like if I was the hype if I was
between like the ages of 14 and like 30
when this game came out yeah I'd
probably make my whole personality about
this game I probably I would probably
Define my entire life on this game
that's why six constantly gets shafted
because this this would literally blow
my [__] mind if this and it still did
in some respect I'll be honest yeah um
it was really impressive I really
enjoyed it um I I yeah I I like it best
jrpg you've played thus far uh
jrpg yeah yeah I'd say so okay I'd say
so I think I think you know the problem
is final F Final Fantasy 7 fans are
annoying as [__] I'll say it they suck
they they they are obnoxious and this
happens whenever a fan base knows their
game is goated they just become entitled
and they know their game is [__] a
banger it's like the Zelda fans who
constantly prays off it's the one piece
fans Now isn't it yeah and the one piece
fans becoming it and it's like hey we
get it but and I understand the the
visuals are a huge barrier and it's and
it's it's okay to say that the polygons
look [__] weird egg beeter looking
ass they have the [__] chunky arms
and and no [__] biceps yeah but the
story is a banger yeah all right and uh
absolutely amazing yeah but would you
would you recommend just playing this or
playing or waiting for the remakes I I
do recommend playing the original cuz
obviously people can be like oh watch
the original read the the manga all that
[__] I was like I only get to experience
this story for the first time once you
know what I mean and I'm like if this if
you've already started playing the
Remake I think you should just see the
Remake till the end and then if you're
interested in it play the original game
I don't think it's maybe it'll be like
an AA situation where oh the rebuilds
are like such a different thing that
builds on the original and then maybe
I'll play the original but I mean as
someone who started playing the remakes
after playing the original countless
times as a kid like I'm still really
enjoying the remakes I think one thing
that will not be repli in my opinion
that I I haven't seen the new games yet
but one thing that I just don't think
that they'll be able to replicate to the
same extent there's no shot they can
make the music hit as hard in the remake
the music was so I I don't give a [__]
about music the [__] music in this
game was so good oh dude like every
Final Fantasy game is some of the best
like game music like Square does not
miss when it comes to music why did the
music goes so [__] hard in every
every section of this game because
ridiculous the music section of Square
softer just full of goats that's why
even if they just remake the [__]
trucks but but I feel like the
PlayStation the cuz they were so limited
back then why the hardware the the the
the unique sound of the PlayStation back
then was so [__] fun and nice and
epic and I agree with you I I can't even
though you can probably get like these
giant orchestras you get this full you
know [__] dot wav [__] 48,000 KZ
quality perfect you know it's like but
there's something that was so good about
hearing the PE like the PlayStation
sounds so [__] to this day when you
hear the original One-Winged Angel that
was it is absolutely [__] insane I
want to go watch the Final Fantasy
concert the for seven concert I want to
go watch it now cuz that was [__]
fire because I remember playing uh the
latest Final Fantasy Final Fantasy 16
right and you know there were some like
epic moments obviously it has great
music I don't remember a single track
from it on to the top of my head and I'm
like I I remember being I remember being
some of the in some the boss battles
being like oh this feels epic but all I
can remember about the music is just it
match visuals epic epic Orchestra track
that's all I remember and I was like I
can't really remember anything else
about the music although I am hyped for
them to remake the Knights of the Round
Table uh summon oh yeah that was so
[__] ridiculous when I booted that up
and I was like what the [__] is there's
this this's this summon animation that's
like an hour like an hour long for one
attack it's so ridic ridiculous I'm it's
like a whole film it's so ridiculous um
but yeah that great game very very
excited for it um fear and anger yeah
man I mean this kicked off we we know we
know about this one I talked about it
but it was so good it came out in 2018
but obviously I discovered it this year
uh and my God what a [__] game what a
game I still think in terms of RPG I
still enjoyed this and I was more
encapsulated by the world than even
Final Fantasy 7 I was I was [__]
hooked it was so dark so gritting and
the gaml even though it was [__] RPG
Maker was so [__] compelling that it
got me to be like hold on now let me
figure out what's going on in this world
why is it so [__] up yeah because I
was just so enth thralled in it and I
really really really want you boys to
play it uh please do because it's so
[__] amazing and if you haven't
played it uh I'd recommend playing it go
check it out it's it's so goed it's so
good and risk of rain to which I see you
play quite a lot I I played a lot this
year didn't come out talk about this I
didn't really talk about it on the
podcast no really um do you know
anything about risk R 2 I don't know
anything RIS played RIS R 2 yeah yeah
yeah what when uh played it a while ago
uh alone no I had a I had a friend with
um was addicting it's so [__]
addicting kind ofes these kind of games
don't really appeal to me but I remember
we played for like 3 hours or something
just trying to grind it out uh basically
you have uh every you spawn into like a
level and there's a teleporter and you
can go to the teleporter at any point
and fight the boss so if you click on
the teleporter you have to stay in the
zone and a big boss will spawn you kill
the boss you get to go to the next level
now around the area are powerups right
so you need to get the power ups and
then go to the boss and kill them
however uh there's there's one drawback
and it's that the longer you are taking
it in general the harder the game gets
right the more enemies spawn the longer
you the more enem SP the more Health
they have the more damage they do and so
it'll go from like easy normal hard very
hard extreme death ha right lau and then
like it just gets to the point where the
game is so [__] hard that you can't
you can't beat it so you need to you
need to get to the final stage and beat
the boss the final boss before you kind
of get too weak so you have to kind of
balance between like do I just [__]
go for it without the power Ops or do I
risk it being more difficult with power
yeah and it's just a very it's a very
and there's tons of classes tons of
characters it's very stylized um it's
very arcade like feeling um and I played
it a lot with mouse and Pete and we just
had such a [__] good time and I put
so many hours into this game and I had
so much fun um and it really kind of
captured that energy of when I first
played COD zombies as like a teenager
that kind of like oh [__] this is just
fun doing the exact same thing over and
over again um the gameplay was so tight
it was just a really [__] fun game
it's a it's a great game to play with
friends because I played this at a
gaming bar and I was like what the [__]
is this yeah yeah I played this at a
gaming bar and we just had like a bunch
of people together and I'm like oh I'm
[__] addicted because with it's it's
the last time I remember feeling that
kind of like couch gaming where all your
mates are just together trying to like
achieve something together and it was
just really really addicting right yeah
yeah exactly exactly it's really fun
every kind of play style
you know there's accommodating that's
also fun cuz only one person can get one
power up so if you pick it up and you
should have given it to your teammate it
just leads to arguments and fun banter
you're like I'm going to take it you're
like no [__] you I should have gotten
that one that would helped me um and
there's just so much like uh wild kind
of combinations of stuff you can add
where it gets ridiculous um your
powerups can be scaled infinitely and
get crazy cuz you can get 99 of a power
up and it'll it'll scale it 99 times and
so it can get like real [__] crazy um
it's just a really [__] good game
yeah it sounds fun um what's the one
there vland Saga oh right V Saga V Saga
I almost I almost didn't recognize it at
first wait is that an anime yeah this
was my anime of the year I think uh jutu
Ka obviously has been a banger but I
think overall this year Vinland Saga
gave me the most complete package that
just made me feel you know what
surprises me about villain Saga season 2
I remember remember when it started
airing everyone was just like everyone
thought that people would get put off by
it because everyone was like I sleep
everyone everyone thought and me
included fans get put off anime fans
can't watch yeah they're like oh my God
it's so slow and surprisingly I think
I've seen more even more posit well not
really surprisingly but I'm more
surprised that anime fans have patience
and can recognize Peak fiction when they
see it because this is a much slower Arc
it's much more character driven than the
previous one much less action and uh a
lot of people seem to enjoy it even more
uh yeah it was it was just amazing um
really excited to see where it goes
although I've read ahead a little bit um
and going to be very interesting to see
how they handle still PE it's still Peak
yeah I'm going to be hopefully it it
gets a it continues to get a banger
adaptation yeah um and yeah I think it
was generally my anime of this year yeah
um I can't think of an anime that I F
found more compelling M yeah that's
about it I mean it's the go yeah it is
the Go I mean I feel like this year for
anime wasn't necessarily a weak year uh
at all we just didn't get a lot of the
strongest anime we got this year were
just very much sequels uh and
continuations vinar was a sequel
continuation yeah exactly that's a
sequel in continuation a lot of a lot of
anime there weren't as many strong new
Originals like new Originals or new IPS
coming up this year compared to last
year I thought um what's the one on the
bottom right I don't Rec that's that's a
YouTuber I got into it's called Bobby
broccoli yes also [__] good uh I saw
the video where he's talking about that
guy who invented a new
El he's really like I thought I was just
fan art of
you kind of like you me I am my favorite
thing of this year no it's a YouTuber
called Bobby broccoli uh he's probably
my favorite YouTuber that I discovered
this year uh made some absolute bang of
videos I think every single video I get
super excited about even if I have no no
interest or don't care about it yeah
this presenting style is so unique uh
and I just find it really really his
editing is really good as well it's just
amazing content uh please go check him
out it's really good if you like
documentary style informational videos
um with fantastic storytelling um please
check it out it's so good so that's
probably my favorite YouTuber thatc this
year also shout out to Frederick for
releasing a [__] 6our online I still
haven't finished that
one [__] years
yeah the one I also want to shout out is
very recently summoning salt released a
a Mike Tyson's punch video and halfway
through the video he talks about himself
yeah because he I remember he did a
video about Punch Out records and it
ended on him being the record he's
currently the record he's really good at
punch out and everyone in the comments
is like so hype when you start hyped
yourself up you go King well was like
when I watched that [__] speedrun
about the blue shell any% and the guy
making the video was the guy who's the
world record holder and I was like oh he
talking about himself in the third
person so based um so yeah also what
else is based is [__] for you that
was probably my favorite I've listened
to a lot of music this year uh I did the
YouTube premium rewind whatever the [__]
it was where I talk about yeah talk
about all the music I I listened to and
I think this would have been higher but
the problem is the tat isn't on any
streaming platforms yeah but I've
definitely listened to him uh more than
I think anything else did year uh just
absolute Banger songs for any occasion I
think I commented on that on your
Twitter because you had Thundercat on
there was thundat yeah it was really
good too I've listened to mainly Funk uh
like Funk with like uh I don't know EDM
I don't know what EDM is I don't know
[__] whatever electronic F beeps and
Boots beeps ands and and City poop which
I got more into again this year I've
been trying to find this record uh on
vinyl for years and the cheapest I've
seen it go for is like $300 I thought he
was selling it as his concert well I go
to the concert wait wait wait wait well
the original pressing yeah they have the
they have the Remake one yeah I I I went
to a bar I just happened to go to a bar
uh like two months ago and I walked in
and it was a wine bar where the guy
played records right and I [__] you not
the only two records he had like he had
he had a collection of records and they
were only de Punk and tats mush and I
was like there ain't no way there ain't
no way like
I was like bro we're the same guy I was
like what the [__] he literally you like
the beeps and boobs too he literally
only had death punk and tat Masa wow he
didn't he didn't even have that many
albums but he because they don't
respectfully they have X but he had all
them on display and it was just those
and he was cycling between t master and
death punk and I was like Bas that's it
boss man's found the I found the best
part I found my local place do they
still make City pop uh no they make City
poop styled like tracks now now that
it's like kind of a trend in the Indie
scene but like you can't replicate cop
was like the like ' 80s was you could
remake 8s sound but I feel like the 8S
is like like pop music in general right
like with guys like the weekend who are
like bringing back the he samples City
poop right but it's not exactly the same
it's not the same thing I I am very much
down let's sample more City poop let's
get the vi let's do because like when
you get when you get into City pop
you're like oh [__] yeah this this [__]
slap
cop then through them you're like
they're not making
it where can I get my new fix man I
can't listen to the same 10 songs all
over again that's why I was so hyped to
T is still touring so I was like wait I
got really sad when I started looking up
a lot of the artists that I likeed for
City pop and a lot of them are dead yes
and I was like well I guess they not
performing something and I was like I'd
love to go and like appreciate this
music live fortunately so I was really
happy that at least the goat tats Mas
kind of the father of all of this is
still touring CU it's like I'm still so
[__] you saw him and it's it's been
great conert one concert I couldn't go
to whenever I go to small bars now in
Japan especially like when they're like
themed about music I'll be like I like T
story master and every I swear to God
like this is like a nine out of 10 bar
owners I go to they're like oh yeah I've
watched them live we just start [__]
like going off about how much we love
him yeah saying you love yamas tatso to
like a bar man in Tokyo and is the same
level as like talking to anyone in the
anime industry and being like Oh yeah
berserk my
favorite it's like always great I've
I've been having a great and a lot of
time they'll just start playing it for
me and I'm like thanks man I appreciate
it uh so yeah I've I've you know what a
great album go check it out if you
haven't already fantastic album and
finally uh the deepest breath yeah my
favorite documentary this year about I
wanted to watch this yeah I think if
you're going to watch any documentary
this year this is the one I think the
nature of documentary uh the way that
documentaries are filmed it's so hard
to film a documentary about something
that's unfolding yeah because you don't
know where it's going how you know how
it's going to unfold um you know when
you're filming
right it's it is what just I don't know
why you saying this but reminded me of
this I just remind me of the the [__]
Boogie
29 the the Boogie documentary that came
out this year that was also that was
also a great
documentary feel about that um like this
was the the the the hardest part about
do a documentary is if you do a
documentary about a story that's already
finished yeah you're going back you're
asking people hey what happened you get
a different perspective but it's so so
so rare to to get a documentary that is
so wellmade that is also filming
everything as it's unfolding because you
just don't know where the story is going
to go and and filming stuff is very
expensive film Crews follow people
around is not cheap uh there there's
only so long you can do this for and so
the thing that's really amazing about
this and and soul crushing at the same
time is that all of this is unfolding is
the people are documenting it and
following it uh and and I won't say
spoil much about it but uh it is
probably the most like gut-wrenching and
and heartbreaking story uh a documentary
I've watched in a very long time and I
really really cannot stress enough I
don't give a [__] about diving uh but it
is just a fantastic very it's like an
hour and a half just watch it it's
amazing yeah you will have a great time
and I'm so glad they didn't drag it out
into like nine episodes like Netflix
loves doing yeah um I think a lot of
documentaries can be told in two hours
just keep doing that not every [__]
court scene has to be eight [__]
episodes I don't need to find out about
everything just this is just the golden
example of how to make an amazing
documentary with the added bonus that it
was being filmed as it was all
unraveling right which is so so rare
um really really good and the Boogie one
was also that was amazing too but but my
God special shout out to the Boogie one
but my [__] God what a [__] sad
piece of media um he's just a terrible
person I did not know why he agreed to
do it I know why he agreed to do it cuz
he needed money yeah he's broke yeah
that's true cuz he needed more attention
we're talking about we talking about it
now cuz documentary yeah but like I
watched him on the financial there's a
this guy does a video it's called
Financial audit and he was on this and
the guy was going through his finances
and I just it was like [__] bashing
your head against the wall he's like no
I don't I don't need out that much he's
like you spent $900 a month on going out
he's like well I need to do that he's
like why he's like well cuz I can't feed
my family like I can't feed four people
uh unless I go to fast food for cheap
and he's like you can go to the grocery
store he's like well I like the taste
and it's like you are just you are
ruining your life and you have an excuse
for every single time you ruin your life
this episode is sponsored by gamer Subs
gamers are you tired of just drinking
water are you tired of hydrating now you
can do it with style the British way
with some gamer
tea what's this not what people who
drink tea sandwich we sound refined and
elegant and that's why I drink only
gamer tea that's a lie I drink other
tees but this one is really good too
they have four types of tea black ginger
turmeric sleepy time and yal matter each
box comes with 15 bags bags should be
added to hot water like you would
normally make hot tea and guess what
Gamers each box cost $15
USD that's $1 per teab bag whoa but guys
that is not the big news because wfu cup
season 5.5 is launching with royalty
guys with a purchase of season 5.5
royalty Wu cup you can get one free box
of your choice of gamer t one of these
ones guys you can spend $30 to get a
free sticker pack spend $75 for a free
shirt spend $125 for a free box of sus
snacks spend $200 for a free lunch date
lunch boox with lunch date Shaker and
all of these tears Stacks while supplies
last I love the tea so much I skipped
the water making part he's two gam for
this world use code trash tast at
checkout for a discount and thank you to
gamer subs for sponsoring this episode
all right finally we can get to my one
all right let's see G Nine favorite
things of this year what the
[__] all right first of all okay okay
what did you your your list is
noticeably more weeb my I 100
girlfriends based thank you it's such
it's such a [__] hilarious show it's
so funny I read the manger of this I
haven't watched the anime yet but the
manger of this I discovered when it was
first serializing and I'm like this is
going to be a huge show yeah I mean I
feel last year uh we did a lot of
traveling we did the tour and stuff and
I remember saying it last last year I
was like I want to play more games and
watch even more [__] last year than I
did last year and I did which is why my
uh my list is very weeb this year but
first off okay so 100 girlfriends isn't
necessarily my favorite anime/manga that
aired this year I want to keep that one
a secret because I'm literally doing
like a best of list uh this is the one
that surprised me the most though I
think it surprised everyone I came into
100 girlfriends thinking haha this is
going to be a funny meme show that maybe
I can get like one joke out of and then
I started watching it and I'm like why
is this actually really funny it's so
funny why is this why does this concept
unironically work and as as I read
further and further on into the manga I
I found myself thinking why am I getting
invested in these characters it does not
make any sense that's exactly how I felt
reading the manga cuz I like I randomly
found in a bookstore and it was only
when volume one had come out and I was
like oh okay this looks like a kind of
dumb fun thing to read so I picked it up
and I was like holy [__] when's When's
the next volume coming can you guys tell
me about the premise cuz I don't know
anything uh so it's a guy who gets a 100
girlfriends yeah so it's a guy who
during his middle school era didn't uh
couldn't be like wasn't wasn't getting
any girlfriends at all so he goes to a
shrine where he prays to like a shrine
that like specializes in love to be like
I want you know I want to get a
girlfriend going into High School blah
blah blah guy comes down and he's like
I'm going to give you I'm going to make
you the ultimate rizzler yeah and
basically he made it to the point where
he's like you will have 100 girlfriend
by the end of your high school or you
have 100 soulmates yeah you'll have 100
soulmates um but but he can't choose the
soulmates they just happen randomly be
nice yeah so by the so like by around
like you know girlfriend number two or
three it's already getting pretty
chaotic but then later on when he starts
to have like 10 20 different girls into
the picture 26 27 right now yeah it just
becomes so chaotic but the way that all
the jokes are written is so funny and so
left field and absurdist that it just
makes the whole concept ridiculous
basically if you've ever watched a Haram
anime or Haram manga it takes all of
like the most ridiculous tropes in that
genre and just expands on that and just
like I mean the concept totally makes
fun of the Haram yeah I mean the concept
is him getting 100 girlfriends so your
suspension of disbelief is already like
[__] shattered anyway so it just
takes everything that you think is
ridiculous about that genre and just
amps everything up to and even more just
like ridiculous level also godamn like
if picking best goal in a show was hard
enough this show has made it impossible
cuz literally every girl is likable in
some way and you think okay he's going
to do like 100 girlfriends he's going to
do like 10 or something and then
everyone else is going to be background
character and we're like 150 chapters in
and he's given every single girl the
same amount of care and time they get
just as much screen time as and it's
[__] insane that he's or like the
team are actually trying to go through
with this concept and play it out
completely straight um it was my biggest
surprise of the year cuz I thought it
was just going to be a meme show but I'm
completely caught up and God [__]
damn it I need more yeah yeah it's such
a good show so this this is my it's
going to be somewhere on my list that's
a spoiler but this is my biggest
surprise of the year in terms of anime
uh I said last year that I was going to
get into the trail series God and I
haven't joined you
about 200 hours in right now like I was
I was getting a bit rough it was getting
a bit rough like 100 hours in but now
like 200 hours you're too I'm like
godamn this [__] slaps all right I
finally [__] get it so um I'm
currently in the fourth game in the
series now this is my favorite game that
I've played so far how many games are
there again remind me about 10 11 so far
it's long yeah I mean here's the thing
so it really really does take a while to
really set up its world and it really it
it took me a whole year to get through
like the first two games just because
some of that some of those parts were
just such a big drag because they really
don't like they they don't exactly give
you a competing plot line originally
they just let you explore the world
naturally and I'm like God [__] damn
this is uh this this this is long this
is really really long but I feel like
once you get through part but once you
get past one of the games where you get
invested in the world now that I'm
invested in the world even though you
have that same formula you know like
let's say a one piece Arc you go to a
new island and that first few episodes
It's just exploring that island and
you're like well okay what the hurry up
yeah but now because I'm so invested in
this world that part when they go to a
new arc is already interesting to me is
already really really interesting to me
because I'm already really really
invested in the world and the stories
connected between the games and the
stories are connected so you get to a
new chapter and you're like oh it's the
main character from the last one or oh
it's the it's this person and like the
part the part that really like the part
when I really really started get to get
interested is so it's kind of very very
it is basically the one piece of jrpgs
where they you you talk they you go
through the storyline and you hear like
a story about this this epic guy who has
changed the world who is an S-Class
[__] in this Guild and you're like
who the [__] is this guy and then this
guy [__] shows up and starts like
wrecking [__] and then there's another
guy that also shows up and is like even
better than that guy and he's just like
affecting the whole world politics after
like one decision and you're like holy
[__] this is like they they they have
built up these characters in such a in
such an organic way and then they come
onto the screen and they and they make
their presence known and they completely
live up to the legend that has been
built up and it's I am just starting the
I I mean I'm just at the start cuz I've
only finished the first Arc but now that
I've seen some of the payoff that can
that has happened with just this first
Arc going through um I'm going through
like uh trails from zero right now and
seeing some of the characters from this
Arc show up in the arc that I'm going
through now as Side characters and
seeing some other major players that
were only just mentioned in the first
Arc that like some kind of like big
legendary characters and seeing them
kind of show up in this Arc it's really
really [__] exciting to a to a point
that I can't really think of any other
game series that has given me this I can
think of anime series like something
like one piece where you hear of
Whitebeard for example and then
Whitebeard shows up and you're like holy
[__] yeah because most jrpgs like
like Final Fantasy for instance like the
stories aren't connected between games
right unless it's like you know 10 and
102 for example but like you don't
normally have like a long long running
like you know 10 plus game series where
all the stories are connected so like
yeah you you definitely get invested
like that's built to be invested into oh
totally and like and I really want to
join you but damn it looks daunting oh
it it is that's why I didn't really
playay any other jrpgs this year I was
like I'm going to play everything else
first and then eventually I'll get to it
my jrpg journey has just been trails in
the sky and the trail series and that
has been enough committed very hard he's
committed and I think it have to be for
this game yeah and I will say one thing
that's similar to the uh similar to
Final Fantasy how you know you have a
good game series is that everyone seems
to have a different
opinion which one is the best game so
when I started this everyone was just
like you're going to get to Trails of
the sky third some people say it's
skippable I think it's not but it's with
it's one of the slow ones and then you
like it a lot and then this has been my
favorite one so far this is actually the
game that got me invested in the series
just that's crazy you play three games
not invested yet that's that's
that's I mean I was I was like I was I
was invested but this is this was like
this game out of all three because the
first two are more traditional jrpg
where it's just like big epic storyline
world ending thing happening and then
Trails of the sky third is just hey
Slice of Life hey massive law dumps
about what has led the world to this
situation I'm like holy [__] this is
actually really [__] inter I had a
similar experience with like xenor blade
for instance like I didn't fully get
invested into the Xenoblade Universe
until the third game yeah and it took me
one and two to finally be like all right
this series is kind of goed yeah so I
totally get it all right so you also put
honai yeah I mean I would be lying to
myself if we we we talked about the
games that defined our year is I needed
to put a gacha game on I mean I played
so much honai star ra this year like
obviously I was sponsored to play it but
also I played it a lot in my free time
as well and I kind of just feel like
this was Hoya versus like everything
that they've been building up to kind of
coming together into a product that's
it's tapping a market that I don't think
has been tapped in the gaming industry
so far I hope we have a honai ad in this
episode it'll be it'll be great w we
won't godamn it I mean you like of
course we all love to clown on gacha
Gamers rightly so especially [__]
hoyse gacha Gamers but I do feel like
their success comes down to them tapping
into a market uh of Gamers that was that
I am you know and it's the casual gamers
yeah for sure I mean in terms of mobile
games I think they're definitely making
like the most complete products yeah
yeah definitely yeah I mean people just
clown on gcha in general right but cuz I
mean you you already talked about we
already had this conversation with tears
of the Kingdom yeah where we see this
hyped up new game coming out and we want
to play it but we do not have the time
or the commitment to dive into this
world right now and part of the reason I
you know genuinely respect ho ver what
they're doing is they are making a
product that you can put as much time
into it as you feel like putting into it
but it also with hongkai star rail it's
the first time I got a payoff that I
would normally experience with a
so-called AAA game and it was just it
hit me out of it hit me out of left
field so much that it was probably one
of the gaming moments that stuck out to
me just because I was not expecting it I
mean in a lot of ways honai is almost a
AAA game if you think about it cuz like
the it definitely isely for sure right I
think people still don't recognize it
maybe they do but like at least the I
think there's there's this part of
gaming which I think is very fair where
like I don't we don't want to reward
games that require money right uh which
I think is fair I think a lot of Gamers
they they don't respect games that maybe
they you can I know I know I know you
can do freeo playay and all that stuff
but a lot of Gamers don't respect games
that are like hey money please we can
help you right um and I think that's
that that's valid I think uh we as an
industry probably shouldn't reward games
that do that right you're like we want
more of the trails in the sky which
presumably has no yeah yeah you want to
reward games that hey this is a complete
game give it to me you know like um I
think people prefer that and that's
almost why people don't want to talk
about honai or genshin as these AAA
games they want to keep them in the
mobile game category like we don't want
you to mess with our Pure gaming which
already been [__] up a bunch micro
microtransactions but but I understand
why they why a lot of people feel that
way yeah at the same time I would love
more products like this you know if if
if we keep this in let's say the mobile
market where people aren't a fan of like
the gacha system whatever my big appeal
towards honai and genin and other games
like that is the respect of my time is
that I can put as much time as I want to
put into it maybe you know sometimes I
want to just log on and just game for
like pick up and play pick up and play
and one thing that they really cornered
that didn't really exist before was how
easy it is to pick up and play whatever
console whatever place you want to do it
in so like you want to play it on PC
great you want to play it on mobile you
can do that you it might not be the same
gaming experience but you can do it you
know and it just makes it so much more
accessible to me and accessibility is
such a big reason why they have blown up
so much in my opinion even though they
get on by a lot of people yeah one thing
I I don't respect about the games in
general is the whole having to do daad
quests grinding all the time doing all
the stuff but I know it's how they keep
you invested it's how they keep you in
the game so when they release DLC you
care about it yeah yeah for sure but I'm
just me personally I'm just not looking
for an a gaming experience that requires
me to to grind yeah I to me that's like
the biggest slap in like you could turn
my money but don't [__] take my time
and [__] all over me all right all right
this might be a hot take all right this
definitely is a hot take okay it was
after playing hongkai Star rail don't
say what I think you're about to say
that I genuinely was like I would like
more Auto Battlers oh [__] no enabled in
other jrpgs oh my God and okay okay
here's what I realized because there
there there are the two RPGs that are on
here right now trails and honai star
right and TR the trail series you know
I'm sure you experienced this with uh
final fin fantasy as well there are
certain segments where I am doing
[__] nothing except going through the
world and tapping a or tapping tapping
attack well yeah I mean but like this is
a an RPG and jrpg problem specifically
where they they have not figured out how
to keep you on your toes without like
Random Encounters or battles that that
do it but a lot of the times you can
just Mash through it but I feel like
that's kind of going away a little bit
now you know like you now nowadays you
can choose who you fight so you can just
walk through the field without having to
bump into any of the enemies you don't
want to fight right like there's a lot
of these new aspects where they've
learned that hey maybe throwing a
[__] mob at someone all the time is
not helpful or B is the this is like
this is like inventing a new disease and
then giving you the Cure you know what I
mean that that's what they're doing they
haven't fixed the problem they're just
making a new problem and giving you a
new cure this is the pharmaceutical
industry all over again well that's
that's what I that's what I like respect
heavily about the Persona series is that
like you know you do have this like kind
of idle time between significant story
portions of the game and this is like in
almost all the Persona games where like
you have the option of you can go to the
Dungeons and grind for experience or you
can go and do these other things and I
think just like having that choice I
think is like a nice balance of like it
doesn't force you to be like all right
uh for the next five in-game uh days you
have to go to the Dungeons and grind
otherwise you're not going to get to
this next point you don't have to do
that right so I think just like more
jrpgs are starting to kind of throw in
other options that don't necessarily
equate to you having to grind terrible
take by the way guys on the record I
don't agree we need at least one I don't
agree because here's here's the thing
okay CU I realized this during Trails of
the sky uh or the trail series in
general how old is that that that game
the one that Charles in the sky or
whatever the one you're I mean I I I've
I'm even playing through the new trail
series right now here's like here's the
thing I most what I really realizes that
most of
the um Good Feeling the satisfaction I
get from playing the Jr from jrpg
systems isn't so much the battle itself
it's the preparation to that battle
right it's getting the uh and I realized
this because now that I've complained
about the whole item system in Trails
before there was a moment in Sky third
where it just clicked and then I just
had such enjoyment seeing like you know
getting all these different combination
of ORS into this one character and
building like the perfect team comp to
do all that's part of the fun and then
you know you go through most of it and
then it's I only really got the
satisfaction during the big boss battles
you know during the big challenging boss
battles everything else was just me kind
of like going through a dungeon and me
just like tapping a I mean that's
problem with that game not a problem
that that they solved with auto battles
I can't think of a Jr jrpg that does has
that hasn't felt like that this way uh
Persona kind of offset that to me
because it felt like Persona was kind of
it the the way the way that Persona did
it was the music was so good and it it
felt like a weird exper it almost felt
like a rhythm game playing it with the
music you know what I mean and
especially Persona 5 the battle theme
being one of the hardest bangers that
Alice has ever made you know a lot of
the times you can you by the skin your
teeth you can beat a mob right and you
can get lucky so I think the reason why
a lot of these games had that back in
the day or why I'll continue to do it to
an extent is that like hey if every
single normal enemy you're coming across
is kicking your ass yeah you got to go
back yeah you got to go train out or you
got to rethink your strategy here so I
think it was just an easy way of being
like hey get to this level for this part
yeah um but the solution is not Auto
battling that is like that's that's like
the solution to heroin is SW swapping to
Like Cocaine it's it's it's not it's not
the solution but it is a patch that I
would especially through some of the
[__] old
jrpgs uh oh my God yeah some of you know
play fanty I [__] wish I had but
that's the problem with the older jrpgs
is that they weren't aware of those
struggles at the time because it was
still a newer concept and also back then
gaming has also changed now where people
have so many games to choose from and
now the issue is not am I getting a game
that's worth my time sorry money it's am
I getting a game that is is resp
respecting my time so back then it was
like oh my God [__] yeah I can get 120
hours out of this game it's like now
it's like oh my God they're going to
waste 120 hours my time for what could
have been a 12 hour experience so so I
think it's not so much that like oh it's
hey this is respecting my time it's like
why are they not respecting my time and
then giving me a solution where they
clearly recognize they should respect my
time but they also clearly are like no
no come back please please waste your
time on us cuz that's how we that's how
we get our monies and we get engagement
get our monies so I I terrible take gone
L take no it would make it would make me
enjoy turn-based combat even more uh
because I [__] hate him I [__]
hate turnbas combat for this exact
reason so um yeah I mean like to me I
separat I separate jrpgs into dungeons
which is just but like brain dead brain
dead decisions where I'm like I'm not
ready going through this dungeon to make
any any meaningful go go from my time
playing honai uh I felt like there was
uh like no depth to the combat
system what' you mean like I play Final
Fantasy right this is a 26-year old game
yeah there's the material system what a
banger I can make anyone in my party the
Healer I can make anyone in my party the
tank I can make anyone do damage in any
kind of way I want to I can mix and
match all of these systems but that's
because they're not limited by having to
tell you hey by the way this guy's a
six-star and his thing is fire and he's
really good at fire so you should get
him and use him well and I feel like
that is a limitation that has been
spawned of Gater is that you have taken
away my ability to customize my
characters and play the game the way I
want to play it you're like like this is
this character they heal good this is
this character they do true damage
they've been pre selected you have now
made the combat so boring that auto
battling is the only way I can
experience this game like you you the
only way you have made this game
interesting is by making the bosses
harder thus making me have to think oh I
need this character not oh I I need to
think about how to customize my
character better to to to combat the
situation um I feel like it's almost
ruined like well it ruined it it almost
it almost like here's here's the thing
about these kinds of games which is like
yes I agree which is you if you have
every [__] five star in the game it's
all it is is going to be you're playing
for the story which is kind of what I'm
doing right now but isn't that sad that
you can just get these characters if if
you actually want to be a gamer the best
way to play is to play freeto play
genuinely genuinely because but then I
have to go through like hours of
grinding and [__] no no no no because
with free to play you have to learn to
play with the material that you havee
you got you actually have to strategize
and it's it's like a totally different
it's almost like a totally different
experience to someone who is a [__]
whale who wants to grind for every
artifact when you go freeo play you may
you actively have to play with what you
are given and that is always randomized
and no it doesn't like yes it feels good
to get a five star and all that stuff
but this like there are you know it it
makes it more similar to let's say like
a rogalik where you you the material
you're given is randomized and you have
to play with what you have so that's
what you know that's I talk about a game
like this where yes it's easy to clown
on but you can approach the game any way
the way you want to approach the game
you know and that that is the beauty of
it where you can just be a [__] Deen
and just be pay to win but don't you
feel like sometimes because of the way
that they've Incorporated GAA which is
hey get this character they strong that
it it has limited what all the
characters can do subsequently because
now this is the strong one this is the
weak one You Can't customize him bro you
play a you you talk to real Gadget
Gamers and they don't roll based on they
they roll based on who the [__]
sexiest wife is I know what I'm saying
is like hey I don't even like this
Banner character but I have to
get I think it's fair to say that hey
we've we've somehow made the combat
worse but we've made it flashier and so
we're like oh I think it's better I no I
I totally agree where the depth compared
to [__] Trails or Final Fantasy I I
totally I totally [__] this is the
Bare Bones like the like the Bare Bones
depth you can ask for there is tiny tiny
tiny but to me that's what makes it a
great casual game it's just turn your
brain off kind of it took it took me
like 80 hours to really fully like gel
with the trails battle system I I didn't
[__] need that for honai man I don't
[__] need that for honai sometimes I
just don't want to don't want to think
too much I've now secured you a Year's
worth of honkai sponsorship but allowing
you to defend it yeah you're welcome we
just made G fore this just proves that I
is like yes G we've made the correct
decision here this just proves I have
the worst taste in games out of all of
us the fact that yes I know it's a
shitty take yes I know I'm a shitty
gamer but that's the kind of gamer I am
okay I'm a lazy gamer I'm a [__] lazy
gamer just give me story give me World
building that's what I've really F give
me the
bag all right so uh let's let's cuz we
spent like 19 hours there day all right
uh what's this uh middle left
one this is a [__] amazing M such a
good manga what is it tell me about it
okay so guy wakes up in a hospital he
has Amnesia cliche right very cliche
yeah yeah except for some reason he's
found out that he's woken up and he has
a family and everyone in the family has
Amnesia and they don't know what
happened they don't know why they they
all know their family yeah they they
were told that they were family and they
go on a car accident together and they
all have amnesia um and so you know they
kind of like it's this really wholesome
story about this entire family who just
have like Amnesia and they are told that
they're family but can you be family if
you just like told that you have this
bond with each other so they kind of
like it's it's a story about them kind
of like reconnecting and rediscovering
what it means to be a family I want I
want to know necessarily use the word
wholesome wa wait wait Joey Joy Joey
Joey God [__] damn it Joey God
[__] damn it let me let me real I
didn't realize you're building up so my
bad my bad okay so so yeah it's a story
about them discovering their bonds and
like they're slowly discovering hey [__]
we like being a family together we this
is what being a family means and then
they finally get discharged from the
hospital they go home he the main
character goes in goes into his room and
his room is just filled from ceiling to
ground with the words die like just
scribbled like everywhere just like
something something has gone on and he
rushes out and he's [__] panicking
and every single family member has had
that same reaction after going to their
rooms they're just like they they're
like guys uh yeah what's uh what the
[__] let's have a meal right and they
don't talk about it and you're like holy
[__] what has happened to this family
and that's chapter one oh wow right Co
and as the story unfolds you
realize what has gone on with each
different family member some of the
[__] up [__] that has happened behind
the scenes that we don't know about
because for some reason everyone has
Amnesia and without spoiling it that's
pretty
coincidental car with the carbon
monoxide yeah and that's pretty unusual
that they all happen to have amnesia and
it's it just started this year and it's
it's rare that I have a manga that just
immediately gripped me from chapter one
and this is what I it's still [__]
good this is what this is the page
Turner manga for me okay you finish the
chapter you're like there's a Twist and
you're like holy [__] I need to read the
next one I need to read the next one
honestly it's this Artist as well
because uh they did it one before this
one called Taco noai uh which is kind of
in a similar vein where like there's
this alien creature that this girl finds
called tuckle and uh and he like tries
to like you know befriend this like
alien kind of creature and something
happens to her and in her vicinity that
is like absolutely [__] up um and tule
this character uh realizes that like he
can only once every couple of like
periods of time that they can teleport
back to the past at a certain point and
so this girl uses this this alien's
power to go back in time to try and like
fix her future of like the [__] up
[__] and this
author has this really interesting style
where like they have such a cutesy
wholesome looking
like but has created some of the most
[__] up stories all right I'm Sol that
sounds awesome and this one is as well
is really fun like whoa and I first read
it this one hits the ground running and
it hasn't stopped yet T as well like
first chapter is just [__] yeah yeah
exactly okay I'm sold you sold me boys
and that's all I'm going to say about it
because it is a mystery manga so I don't
want to say too much so read it
yourselves I guess just read it your I
just wanted to sell I just wanted to
sell it uh one live AC I keep thinking
about this I keep having people come to
me and ask me about it you know what now
in retrospect after many months it's
been since I finished watching this I
think I finally realized just how much I
enjoyed the [__] out of this live action
right like I think I came I think I came
into this too much as just a seasoned
Anime Watcher who had just been Jed
we've been burned I I think when
everyone's like see guys we told you
going good it's like no no no no you
guys have [__] this up for like 30
years back to back you don't you don't
get to just be like see we were right it
was going to be good now [__] off I
think everyone everyone was very
Justified and their worry about hearing
this oh totally but obviously everyone's
very relieved that it's good yeah and
the more friends and more family members
that have absolutely zero interest in
anime because more keep coming up as
like I just as the years going on where
they just kept asking me about one piece
and I just it just made me realize holy
[__] this was this is why every studio
is trying to make a live action and this
is now the standard of big high-profile
liveaction adaptations because it just
kind of especially Western production as
well yeah especially Western Productions
and I really really hope that we haven't
opened Pandora's box with this one we
have uh I mean you HW show live action's
coming out and I'm really scared that's
already out oh is it out already yeah
well I know what I'm watching I okay
actually have you seen it I've seen a
few episodes and it's actually pretty
decent oh okay W there is there is this
one fight scene because one of one of
the big things that I didn't know what
how they were going to do was cuz I
think the first Arc of uoki was one of
the weakest ones well yeah it starts off
as a slice how do you make it compelling
yeah they had this one fight scene with
one of the demons that very much felt
like a jackiechan movie or like an old
school Kung Fu like the camera work in
that was [__] insane it's not just T
yeah I mean yeah theoretically if it you
know these people now are being brought
up on anime who are directing these
things and watching it it should it
should get better and you know if one
piece has kind of set the the stage now
saying hey look we you can do it then we
should theoretically get more good
liveaction adaptations and it's not to
say they haven't been like you know just
as good live actions or better than the
one piece live action CU like there have
been like there's been a couple of live
actions I've seen that are actually I
think better than the one piece live
action but it's just we had so many
misses in between that time as well yeah
still worried about how they'll continue
with it because that's still the big
question how are they going to bring
Chopper into the equation that's my
biggest question how do they how do they
do this all before they all get old how
do you you know you have to commit this
is It's one of those things where it's
like yeah I think they they've nailed it
now but like going forward is like a
real big question mark and that's was
always going to be tough with one yeah I
think I think they they've done what
they've needed to do uh and they've
introduced one piece to a larger
audience because God forbid one piece
fans are the most toxic now anyway so
what's the hard TV Works G if a TV show
is popular you know we got to get them
Seasons out of you I was going to say
prior to today that I honestly ly think
that this is the best way to get someone
into one piece but oh my God we just got
announced today that one piece is
getting a [__] remake what they're
doing one piece Brotherhood before one
piece is even finished yeah which is
probably going to be now the new best
way to get someone into one piece I I
guess we'll see how how it goes when
they start releasing I mean one piece
fans uh we we've been eating very very
well this year we've had gear five we've
had live action we've had now a new
remake coming out they realiz an
infinite money glitch which is just
using the one piece IP in any way yeah
it's kind of weird to think that one
piece is now peaking after like what 25
years yeah almost 30 years yeah yeah
it's still it's still got new Peaks uh
excited to see where it goes future all
right everything here was way too
[__] vanilla I wanted to throw in
some
spice I I wish I could have put a hent
on mine but there was I didn't think
there was any good hent this year this
one this one looks like really [__]
artartsy like what is this okay so this
is this is this is a d jinci okay uh
that much hentai this year [__] sucks
so bad sucks this is probably the worst
year of hentai since I've started
watching hentai so just so just the
[__] wash your hand yeah definitely
um I wouldn't recommend this dojan if
you want to yank it I'll be honest okay
uh I want I I wanted to put this on
because is this like a metamorphosis
kind of okay yeah I got that Vibe I got
that Vibe I I was like this looks too
dark and gritty I was like man I didn't
realize the menu had a weird ass poster
oh no it's just a [__] big ass blank
box yeah I thought I thought Alex just
[__] up on like the the cropping and I
was just like oh okay yeah um so this
kind of takes place in a cyber Punk
world where basically sex and Androids
exist and uh people can buy sex Androids
so Japan in about 20 years we're close
we're getting yeah we're getting there
in about 20 years and you start like
chapter 2 chapter chapter one chapter
two and you're like oh the art in this
is great it's kind of got like that
cyber Punk aesthetic it it looks like a
yoshitoshi Ab M like like a Serial
experiments Lane Vibe kind of kind of
yeah it's kind of very much that Vibe
the art is great and then they start
like developing the
characters and you're and you're like
okay I'm I'm still like like put your
pants away you're like
okay I'm listening you're like actually
this makes it even [__] better
because now now I'm invested in the
characters as well and then there is
just this one chapter where bad things
happen to the characters yeah and I
don't think I've had that kind of
emotional reaction to a [__] Doan I
think ever wow like with metamorphosis I
think with metamorphosis I was like I
know what I'm getting into I'm like
prepared for it with this one I was just
like having a joy like a jolly old time
and then like you turn the page and
you're like oh oh my god oh is it like
is it like like era guro territory or um
I wouldn't say arur it's it's what the
[__] does arur mean like violent Jes
error it's it it is very much violent
but I the reason I think it's [__]
like because it's like to do with
Androids right to do with you know and
to do with like machines technically
there's like no Gore in it but it made
me realize that it made me feel these
like emotions just because I was that
attached to some of like the Android
characters in it and I was like wait a
minute is this a really [__] good
story as well and so much so you'd
recommend it so much so I recommend
people experience it um this definitely
looks like something I'd get into yeah
yeah yeah I was I was like
here you go just from the look of it I'm
like yeah I think I was like Joey try
this one out try this one out I'll give
it a read I'll I'm going to say I'm not
going to say too much about it but it it
just like I want most of the things I
put on here are things that have
surprised me over the years over this
year because I didn't want to put any
anime on there and most of the films and
games we've talked about already so like
this one uh this one definitely
surprised me uh I wasn't expecting that
and I had a very very strong emotional
reaction and to me that's what art is
all about sure even if you come into
this for a totally different [__]
reason M that
is that is what Art's all about you're
definitely coming into this that's for
sure um I mean this one was not so much
villain Saga season 2 it was how
surprising it was for me that a
wholesome Meme got spread around this
year this was my favorite meme this year
I have no enemies en yeah yeah I we
plent I'm I'm not going to I'm not going
to say too much about this because I
mean it very much build on the power of
villain Saga season 2 and the message
they had in general uh so much so that
it actually gave the internet a
wholesome Meme and I think the internet
could do with more wholesome memes this
year for sure that's true it did it did
kind of get the internet by storm for
about a week or two yeah uh which I
appreciate it's good me the internet was
a safe place for about we so let's talk
about the menu okay the menu what the
did you watch the menu for the first
time this year yeah I did oh nice yeah I
think we I think you one of you guys we
speak about this um I actually think I
started to slowly get into horror movies
this year and I think the menu sydne is
forcing you to Sydney has forced me to
and she's failed many many times and I
think I'm slowly discovering the um so I
I was I had a tough choice between two
horror movies I wanted to put on here
one was the menu the other one was all
my friends hate me which is what John
recommended I actually went out and
watch watched it okay and that one I
still think about that one like I I
finished that film and I was like I hate
it but then I had the same kind of
reaction as the bo Heron where I can't
stop thinking about it so I'll talk
about the menu first um I realiz I
realized what I liked about what I like
is the feeling of
uncomfortableness in horror films maybe
not so much like or bad things or scary
things happening like Thriller like I
wouldn't call it so much Thriller cuz
Thriller I I felt like horror was a
consequence of the general story and not
the intention like in a weird way I
don't know how to that makes sense like
I didn't feel like a horror film cuz and
with horror films I don't like it when
they when you get into the movie and
immediately they're like it's a horror
film we got a horror Trope horror Trope
this this was like this is a film that
divulges into horror um because of and
you know like it has horror elements to
it but I mean it's definitely Horror by
the end but it was still very very I
really enjoyed this film watch this with
this one I I I think what drew me to it
was that feeling of uncomfortableness of
knowing that something's not what it
seems to be but you can't quite put your
finger on it like that uncanny valley
feeling oh yeah no no okay that totally
is it it's that uncanny valley feeling
of just being in a situation and not
knowing what's wrong but knowing
something is wrong something is off and
the way that they build this [__] up and
then you pay it off being like haha this
was the thing that was going on in the
background all the time I think this one
had the like one of the best payoffs I
have where it was kind of like
satirizing the whole fine dining yeah
really good I really really enjoyed it
and also the actor playing the chef just
Ral R fines what what's his name again
graines or Colin F I can't remember
which one it was which one is it it's
not Colin F right am I crazy is it Rines
I mean yeah ra Rines is [__] amazing
in everything what else is he in he's in
so many things [__] he's in uh Kingsman
uh he's in uh who is he in Kingsman uh
he's like the MI5 like this is what
you're going to be doing uh that
explained it this is what you're going
to be doing this is your like uh your
job ralin plays as the this is what
you're going to be he's the Nazi and
Schindler's List like the god oh oh he's
uh in the grand pest Hotel he's the
concierge uh the kingsman oh okay yes I
do know this actor then this man is in
so many films that you've probably
watched he's Voldemort uh oh he's
Voldemort Voldemort he's in uh so he's
just the bad guy in uh yeah he's a bad
guy in every
film Skyfall he's in the he's in Jam as
well Prince of Egypt he's in Lego Batman
um [__] wals and grommet um [__]
great film um he's in uh [__]
Sunshine um in he dude he literally go
through his filmography it is literally
like backtack bangers damn he's he is
such a [__] good actor and when he
was the main guy main guy in this I was
like I know it's going to be whenever
he's in anything on the poster it's
going to be a [__] good time he's
such a [__] good actor um and I
absolutely love watching him and he was
so good in this yeah I think the scene
that like really I keep thinking about
is I you've seen the menu right yeah
it's the burger scene yeah see see just
seeing this childlike Joy of someone
cooking like this fine dining Chef
cooking this burger I'm not going to
spoil why he's cooking a burger but he's
cooking a burger and it's seeing this
tired old Chef finding Joy cooking the
one of the simplest meals you can find
was
so weirdly heartwarming in such a
terrifying story I was like oh this is
such a mix of emotions that I'm feeling
right now
I that I thought this is just great film
making with great acting it's not got
the most it's not got the most you know
weird script the most convoluted script
it's a simple story but if you just want
good horror without seeing something
horrific or gory happen watch the menu
if you want a British horror film and uh
this
is I I want to talk about all my friends
hate me or I think I think that's name
it's it's the horror film that John kind
of recommended to me and I would love
for you guys to watch it as well because
I still think about it to this day it's
kind of similar to this where it has
this feeling of
uncomfortableness um something that's
going on in the backgrounds the
difference between that film and the
menu is that there is not this kind of
like big reveal the ending is left to
like your own the the ending is left
more ambigous AIT story yeah yeah yeah
um and that really [__] bothered me
when I finished the film I'm down to
watch but uh the more that time has gone
on the less I can like the more I
[__] think about that film um because
that film I don't like that is the film
I think has given me the most anxiety
this no okay and nothing horrific bad
happens in it I call it a British horror
film because it is it is very very much
based around British
uncomfortableness uh and uh what's the
word awkwardness in British UNC
awkwardness and backhanded right okay
that sounds fun I'm down yeah so so so
okay I I'll I'll tell you the opening
scene right so the opening scene is
there's this guy who is meeting him his
mates from uni they haven't met in
[__] 10 years or whatever and it it's
his birthday and all all of all of his
mates have um have kind of sorted out a
big [__] birthday party for him and
he shows up he's ready to [__] party
it's the middle of the countryside and
it's going to be a massive house party
he shows up he gets the beers out gets
the music out he's like hey guys turns
out the building's completely empty the
building's just complet he's by himself
and he's like oh [__] maybe maybe
everyone's just late maybe they got the
wrong time so he cracks open a Beer by
himself starts spinning on music Waits
an hour passes two hour
passes the entire day pass and he's just
by himself oh [__] and they show up at
9900 p.m. or something and everyone's
like I can't remember the name I'm just
going to John what the [__] you doing
here well we we we gave you a message
that we're going to go to the pub didn't
didn't receive any message and so this
party goes on and weird ADV ADV it's
just weird vibe something's going on
there's some jokes that are made towards
him that are just like are you joking or
was was that a joke or was there some
was was there some bite towards yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then and then he's
just like oh guys it's it's a weekend
long party he decides to go to bed and
um he he just like guys I know it's my
birthday but I'm kind of feeling tired
I'm just I'm just going to call early
cuz we're going to have a [__] Banger
day tomorrow so he goes up and one of
his mates comes up to him and he just
and she goes yeah John can i t you for a
second oh like I I know it's like your
birthday or and everything but like not
going to lie you've been been a bit [__]
today haven't you oh
God
and you know what I mean just like oh oh
kill me now and that kind of
atmosphere continues through throughout
the entirety of this weekend long party
right and you kind of get hints about
what's going on but you never know if
his friends actually have a problem with
him or if it's just like [__] tongue
and cheek and if it's just some some
kind of like sounds good I'm down yeah
I'm investing I I've never made a film
that's made me feel more [__]
uncomfortable in my life okay I'm H I'm
there I don't I'd be interested to see
what Americans think about it because it
is it is this kind of British and I
think austral
uncomfort that Americans just wouldn't
understand cuz with Americans they'd be
like I have I have a [__] issue with
you you know if they wouldn't make like
some [__] backhanded jokes true um
highly highly recommend it um but uh
yeah sounds good uh what's this last one
in the middle last one was the YouTuber
I discovered this year which was
completely out of any kind of like
sphere of Interest I had uh it's this
guy called Fort n okay not fortnite Fort
n mhm
he's a motorbike YouTuber I seen this
guy okay you might have seen this guy
right maybe um I discovered him when I
was going through that my [__] veser
phase when I when I bought my veser I
was I was just looking for you know
videos and I have I have seen this guy
yeah yeah and this he is just I like his
videos he is just a a YouTuber where he
does videos on a topic I have almost
zero interest in but he's such a
talented content creator and talented
well shot and like I love the bits he
always has like very like Cinema esque
bits before he talks about something
it's really cool yeah the the best way
if I have like a sentence elevator pitch
he's just top gear but for motorbikes
and it's one guy and it's one guy but he
is I think he's Canadian I think he's
canadi yeah um but you may have like
zero zero interest in motorbikes at all
but but he presents it in such a way
that it's not only entertaining but it's
informational and thanks to him I I not
only got more into like motorbike
culture but it also I also learned a lot
that I thought I had zero [__]
interesting and also if you just miss
Top Gear and you miss Peak like Jeremy
Clarkson watch fortnite uh he definitely
carries the spirit of that especially
not so much with like let's say the
Special Top Gear episodes but very much
with the weekly Top Gear episodes where
they just review cars but just have a
very very very unique and entertaining
way of reviewing cars cool and yeah that
was pretty much my 3x3 of the Year and
that was our 3x3 of the year that know
down below what you thought about our
3x3 and maybe what your 3x3 yeah what
did you get into this year would love to
know let us know in the comments but hey
look at all these patrons though look at
all them yeah hopefully they were into
trash tasting in 2023 CU otherwise they
wouldn't really be there you know what
I'm saying but hey if you like to
support the show and uh see us sometime
next I mean we're going to have one more
episode before this but to support us in
next year's Endeavors then make sure to
go over to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on Twitter
send us memes on the sub and if you head
up face listen to us on Spotify and we
will see you all next week for the final
2023 trash taste episode all right
[Music]
bye